welcome ladies and gentlemen to Super
Tuesday
it is likely going to be an incredible
night I predict it is going to be a
surprising night in that I believe
because of the shake-up of this race in
the last 48 hours
not yet reflected in the polls I believe
we are going to have final results today
that differ not in significantly from
the latest polling data which we will of
course be reviewing let's start today by
welcoming all of you watching live on
YouTube twitch and Facebook we have some
results which I will get to momentarily
and this has been the last ninety six
and in particular the last 48 hours have
been arguably some of the most this in
in the same way that the stock market
lost 10 percent last week in the
shortest period in history I believe
that this may be the 48 hour period
during which a Democratic primary has
shifted to the greatest degree at least
that I can remember and it's not good
for Bernie Sanders and it's very good
for Joe Biden that is the reality I tell
you things as they are not as you or I
might wish them to be and this is going
to be quite an evening let's start with
the results that we have so far where
you will see that Vermont has already
been called for Bernie Sanders we have
seen Virginia called
for Joseph R Biden Jr we have seen North
Carolina called for Joseph R Biden Jr
and American Samoa which is not here
American Samoa
where was that okay well it's not even
on here American Samoa was called for
Michael Bloomberg and I don't know how
concerned you find folks are with that
the updated delegate counts as of right
now let's get a quick refresh and make
sure we have the latest numbers we have
116 for Joseph Biden 80 for Bernard
Sanders Pete Budaj edge out still with
his 26 Elizabeth Warren ate a meal Oh
Bashar seven and according
one thing I saw Tulsi did get one
delegate she got a delegate in yeah it
still shows zero here but I believe
Tulsi got a delegate in American Samoa
and that may well be her only her first
last final and only delegate in this
entire thing and even that may be wrong
let's review some of the data coming in
as many of you know a South Carolina
which was a very big win for Joe Biden
resulted in a reversal of very
significant reversal in the national
polls you see here what had grown to be
a 12-point two point lead for Bernie
Sanders reversed to what as of today is
almost a statistical tie but again I
believe that these polls do not
accurately refract reflect the momentum
behind Joe Biden don't attack the
messenger I've just believed this is the
reality I believe Joe Biden is going to
over perform these numbers and
ultimately tonight is going to be
determined not by who wins which state
it is really going to come down to the
margins of victory in key states as I
tweeted recently and you should be
following me on Twitter and retweeting
the nonsense that I tweet okay I believe
this is going to ultimately be
determined by the margin in California
Texas or Davis as Michael Bloomberg
corrected a reporter today in
cringe-worthy fashion and to some degree
on North Carolina as well and on that
note let's take a quick look the latest
California polls we have one poll from
two days ago that had Bernie plus 17 and
then we had a poll that was released
yesterday or today that has Bernie at
only plus 7 I believe Bernie Sanders
will not win California by 7 it doesn't
it it pains me to say this
it is only for 53 p.m. on the west coast
it is still possible to go and vote in
California and if you do not like what I
am telling you you can go out and vote
if you haven't yet but I believe that
Bernie doesn't win California by 7
that's my my prediction I think it is
closer than that
and of course with California worth 416
delegates if it is roughly even I mean
if even if Bernie wins by seven it may
not be enough to stave off a drobe ID
and delegate lead by the end of the
night depending what happens in other
places let's look at yes now Texas
known to you the latest poll to latest
polls in Texas have Bernie plus five and
Biden plus two again if you say we look
at the average which is Bernie 1.5 ahead
I think that Biden slightly over
performs that and it ends up roughly
even Michael Bloomberg may be viable in
in Texas as well that's two hundred and
twenty eight delegates very important
and then of course North Carolina
noticed that the average in North
Carolina was Biden plus thirteen point
four with a big boost recently but if we
look at the actual numbers Oh New York
Times doesn't have numbers yet CNN
already had some North Carolina numbers
they were more than plus fourteen four
for Joe Biden so when you ask me and you
say David I hate what you're telling me
but I want you to give me the facts
where do I get the idea that Biden will
over perform in California and yes I get
that impression because Biden was
averaging plus 13 in polling in North
Carolina and the early data that CNN has
had Biden at plus 30 in North Carolina
that likely won't hold to the end but if
it's anywhere close to that it is going
to be a big big night for Joseph R Biden
Jr I am watching all chats if you want
to get a message to me and you're
watching on YouTube these streams are
interactive send a super chat your
message will show up in the lower left
of the screen
see how it's blank right now that's
embarrassing and the reason that it
looks that way
is because nobody has yet sent a super
chat it says no new super chats or
members yet so you can get your message
on the screen by sending a super chat on
you
tube on twitch you can get your message
in the upper right box by subscribing
with either twitch Prime or directly a
few people who have done that while
we've been chatting Shana's has gifted
five subscriptions Thank You Dino Circle
has subscribed for eight months in a row
artistic artistic simplicity has
subscribed for four months in a row
Neptune 99 has subscribed sizz-lorr has
subscribed and Apple Jacks 4 has
subscribed we do also have our first
super chat from a viewer named I hate
juice who doesn't have any comment I
guess their messages what is implicit in
their super chat it is going to be a
night where we will likely know in in
three minutes in fact we are about to
get more results and so will keep it
over here until that time because there
may be more races called
at the top of the hour a North Carolina
results starting to come in and actually
so this is much closer than the data I
saw over on CNN so that is interesting
we will see what results we get at the
top of the hour we have my home state of
Massachusetts closing at the stuff at
the top of the hour we have what else
closes at 8 p.m.
Maine closes at 8:00 and there's some
other states that close at 8:00 we will
see momentarily North Carolina
presumably oh no North Carolina closed
at 7:30
maybe Tennessee what's on the east coast
of Vermont we already have we'll see
we'll see at the top of the hour but we
are indeed expecting some calls there
we do have an out rate I mean it's my
staff almost didn't allow me to do this
but our target today is 100 new members
at join pakman.com my staff told me
David you were going to be embarrassed
tonight you were going to embarrass
yourself tonight you're not going to get
anywhere close to 100 new members that
join pakman.com and I said to them I
believe we will get close I believe it
is going to be a long and and a
productive night of evaluating where
this primary is going and I invite you
to support the stream and there will
another one one week from tonight as we
have more primaries on March 10th join
pakman.com there's a coupon code 2020
now and it instantly saves you 66%
what's better than getting a discount
right I can think of a few things but
not that many
so consider doing that you will
literally start filling up this blue bar
as people do that and I will sing your
praises and say your name as we're
waiting for a few states to close at the
top of the hour let me say thank you to
Joseph Shellabarger for the super chat
name withheld says thanks for covering
David Joseph said the gottsy says who do
you think will sit will exit the race
after tonight I don't know I don't know
I mean you know Warren and Bloomberg are
the question marks but we just won't
know until the results come in bomb-ass
Dan Kass says is the DNC conspiring to
steal it from Bernie well conspiring I
mean there yes yes the answer is yes
they're working together with the
establishment candidates Cody Stegman
says these results are depressing Waller
is me says here you go David out here in
California voted Bernie still hopeful
but I agree with your take on Biden Ryan
Olding hey David why you think Tulsi is
staying in the race I have no idea I
mean she did get a delegate tonight
maybe so I guess that's why incredible
TV says I proudly voted for Bernie by
mail in California feel the burn baby
just let it happen
fingers crossed Pakman will be his VP
pick leggo okay name withheld says vote
Biden for Senator the other Biden for VP
and Bernie for president it is 8 p.m.
and we are expecting results to start
coming in almost literally any second
do we have we see is this yes are trying
to make sure we have all of the latest
data coming up here and we should soon
we should soon be starting to get some
other results let's check our New York
Times election tracker here and see if
anything else has started to come in it
is only 8 p.m. on the dot and the New
York Times tracker very very slow with
their data so to speak it may be
interesting to you to see that as of
this morning the odds had shifted in the
538 election tracker no.1 reaching 50%
plus one delegates now 61% odds Biden
31% odds Burnie 8 nobody else even at
0.1 percent a pretty radical changed
from 96 hours ago let's see what we've
got
polls are closing in Alabama Maine
Massachusetts Oklahoma and Tennessee we
should get more results pretty soon on
quite a few of those states now let's
take a moment to recap some of the
biggest headlines so far of the night
the Washington Post
projecting Joe Biden to win Virginia and
the other states we mentioned Bernie
Sanders to win Vermont meanwhile in
Tennessee voting was extended due to
tornado damage in the area and for the
very latest on where things stand on
this Super Tuesday let's send it back to
the post Jeremy Bauer's at the election
insights team so Jeremy a good night so
far for Joe Biden and you've been
digging more closely into the numbers so
what are you seeing yeah absolutely you
know Joe Biden has been doing
surprisingly well and in places where we
expected him to do well but the things
that are happening in those places were
he expected him to do well is that he's
building really big leads leads that we
certainly weren't expecting based on
things like early like recent polls
we're seeing today's early exit poll
numbers showing just overwhelming
amounts of support for Biden in places
like Virginia and in places like Alabama
and in North Carolina where we were able
to call those races so early and one of
the reasons why all right so it looks
like they don't actually have too much
to add right now I am getting mess I'm
seeing messages from people saying David
we're trying to sign up for memberships
and your website has gone down this
tends to happen at the beginning of
streams we are on a cloud-based server
which adjusts based on demand and it
seems as though when we start a stream
the demand increases so quickly that the
website often goes down
which is a great problem to have believe
me but we have reset the website and for
looking to sign up you should be able to
very very soon and in fact we do have
our first member let me say thank you to
Daniel Rhys who is new member number one
of the evening there it is
thanks so much Daniel I appreciate it
let's see what's on people's minds as we
await results coming in we still have
just Virginia called for Joe Biden
currently plus 30 there oh it was
Virginia that was plus 30 not at North
Carolina I apologize Alabama has been
called for Joe Biden already and North
Carolina has been called for Joe Biden
already here in Massachusetts we're
currently waiting for results as well as
in a number of other states
Cameron Titus says is Warren considered
a strong contender still no Gary
Williams says rooting for Bernie from
the UK Daphne moon says David I'm sad
let's wait for the results to come in
we've got to take it one state at a time
oh boy a lot of super chats coming in
John s says Biden win then Warren being
asked by Biden for be VP I'm hearing
that Kabbalah Kabalah is being
considered for VP potentially and that
would be that would be quite interesting
Julius
Kisuke says what can Sanders do to
increases chances besides somehow
getting Warren to drop out as early as
possible you know I actually questioned
whether Warren dropping out would help
Bernie as much as some think because
what what I've been seeing anecdotally
is a lot of Warren people are saying if
she were out I would vote for Bernie but
a lot are saying if saying if she were
out I would vote for Biden it's not
clear to me that Warren bailing is that
great for Bernie and EB says I want
David's hair thank you also ran says
please explain like I'm five delegates
for u UK viewers well each state has a
certain number of Delegates that is a
portion to it so for example North
Carolina has 110 delegates as you can
see here California a state with larger
population
has 416 delegates so as the candidates
win races they get delegates which are
sort of like points each state is worth
a certain number of points you need 1991
delegates to win the nomination Joe
Biden right now has about 8 percent of
that number Bernie Sanders has about 6%
of that number it's sort of like the
Electoral College where the popular vote
in each state gives you electors in the
presidential election the popular vote
in each state gives you delegates in the
Democratic presidential primary the
Democratic primaries are not
winner-take-all meaning if you get 40%
of the vote in a state you get roughly
you get 40% of the viable threshold
delegates because you need there is a
viability threshold don't need to worry
about that Republican primaries or
winner-take-all they're almost there all
or almost all winner-take-all let me say
a huge thank you and welcome to Joshua
Gelinas who is new member number two of
the evening we have a long night ahead
of us and the best way you can support
the stream it's easy it's fast it feels
good man you go to join pakman.com you
just sign up for a membership the normal
prices I think are very reasonable I
don't begrudge anybody wanting to save
66 percent and if you're in that boat
apply that coupon code above my head
2020 now and you will thus save 66
percent and I will thank you and the
blue bar which is now just a trickle
look at this tiniest bright blue bar it
will start to creep along towards 100
new members tonight let me address some
of the things happening over on Twitch I
want to say thank you to sizz-lorr for
subscribing with prime or no I already
thinks is Laura Andrea Andrea no angry
bag 3000 subscribed for one month
salty dogus has subscribed with Prime
and franglish has subscribed with prime
thank you very much Riley Potter says
couldn't wait for you to
live appreciate you for keeping us
updated also I wish you'd do more videos
or conversations with Kyle coolants key
would be glad to
Paula barrows says Biden won't beat
Trump hi from Amherst Massachusetts
David Oh our old stomping grounds hey
Paula
name withheld says don't be sad Daphne
moon window zombie says Biden won't beat
Trump in the general rest in peace
America ji Vargas says I think it needs
to get a lot worse before it gets better
Trump is going to win 2020 Lori drew
says greetings from Oxford UK greetings
I was just there of six weeks ago
Bernie's brother Larry cast his vote for
Barnard today felt very special
Shaner says saw a cool Vox video on why
primaries are staggered not totally
convinced we shouldn't just do it on a
single day though results shift opinions
listen if it was done on a single day
this could be a different race I mean
half of the momentum Biden has is
because of winning South Carolina the
other half is two candidates dropped out
and endorsed him and that certainly is a
big big factor let's see if we have any
other new data coming in over on the New
York Times tracker we now have data
arriving from North Carolina which is
actually tighter so far than the polls
the initial results have Biden plus
seven Biden plus seven you will notice
that in North Carolina Biden was polling
plus 13 so Biden plus seven is of an
under performance by Biden there in
Virginia Biden was polling plus 17 the
actual results so far are Biden plus 31
so Biden over-performing in Virginia and
then Vermont no question whatsoever it
was always going to Bernie Sanders his
sort of adoptive home state I know you
know that he doesn't have a Vermont
accent he has a Brooklyn accent but as I
lived in Vermont for a long time and
Bernie +30 there Vermont worth I believe
it is 16 delegates going from memory
let's see here I do want to well
a couple of other people who have signed
up let's see here Alexander King is new
member number three mmm excuse me having
a FoxNews moment here new member number
three is Alexander King Johan Bienvenue
is new member number four tonight
Joshua Henry is new member number five
Michael Malone is new member number six
tonight and Arne doll is new member
number seven tonight thank you very much
we do have a very aggressive target of
100 new members tonight I don't know I
don't know we're gonna be here for hours
so I thought what the hell we'll go for
it
let's see here any other projections so
far no we are waiting for results in
Tennessee we are waiting for results of
course in Texas which does not we it
could be a full hour before we have more
results there over on a PBS news hour
they also have live results coming in
and we'll see what is happening there
let me say thank you to a few people
over on Twitch three dollars has
subscribed with prime local 11 has
subscribed with prime ands in 12 21 has
also subscribed with prime thank you
very much I appreciate that
questions continuing to come in via
super chat Sheehan says with will tool
sees one delegate qualify her for the
next debate I don't think so I don't
think so Jimmy Myers says it's my
birthday tomorrow
anyhow are there gonna be a lot of
uninformed people who waste their vote
on candidates who dropped out thank you
yes yes there will Methos mint says
should warren drop out so bernie can
consolidate the progressive vote as i
said earlier it's not obvious to me that
that's what would happen it's it's
depressing to say it but it's not
obvious that that would happen
okay let's see the political are telling
me the Politico Super Tuesday dashboard
is better let me find that for you guys
we want the best dashboard let's see
here Super Tuesday Politico
okay here we go let's see what we've got
so they've got a delegate tracker
popular votes by state
oh this is nice I like this okay so we
have such early numbers starting to come
in so everything that's been called is
above the line beautiful I love it good
suggestion here we have Virginia Alabama
and North Carolina called for Joseph R
Biden Jr Vermont has been called for
Bernard Sanders let's see if there's
anything interesting on the screen so
far in Virginia Biden is right now plus
31 thank you for the suggestion this is
a great great dashboard plus 31 in
Virginia is an over performance for
Biden versus the polls Alabama plus 30
in Alabama I don't think there was much
polling in Alabama so let's see if we
have anything from Alabama to compare to
Alabama Democratic primary oh we do
so Biden was plus 25 in Alabama in
actuality so far he's plus 30 it's it's
an over performance Biden currently plus
13 in North Carolina and you're you'll
recall that Biden was plus 13 in the
polls so Biden right on target there
Vermont a small prize and always in play
for Bernie Sanders we knew that okay
Massachusetts with almost nothing
reporting yet this is where I vote
Massachusetts has Biden out to an early
lead this was a toss-up from the
beginning and the reason why let me find
it
Massachusetts Democratic primary the
reason this was a toss-up is that it is
Elizabeth Warren's home state and in the
absolute latest poll the only one that
included this month Warren was plus two
prior to that it had mostly been Bernie
but then of course when you look at
where Budaj edge had been 14 15 and you
look at Amy Klobuchar 5 to 9 that's
anywhere from you know 17 to 24 points
that will be reallocated and with late
voters going based on exit polls to
Biden it's anyone's guess what's going
to happen in masses
two suits but now with 0.2% reporting
very early it is plus seven or so for
Joe Biden there Oklahoma very very tight
Tennessee looking good early sort of for
Michael Bloomberg although there is a
big three-way race and yes it is
possible that Elizabeth Warren here
could do well in Massachusetts my
prediction is if Warren does not win
Massachusetts even if she grabs some
delegates elsewhere
she will very likely end this race
before the March 10th primaries if not
sooner that's sort of my sense of the
situation right now let's see what else
is on people's minds here let me thank a
few other people who are signing up on
my website new member number eight
tonight is Paula barrows Thank You Paula
I really appreciate your support new
member number nine tonight is David
hammer the way the hammer is gonna be
dropped the bit by the way I let me just
get this out of the way right now before
we go any further
we've got moderators on both YouTube and
on Twitch on Facebook we don't if you're
one of the 150 people watching on
Facebook you're probably able to go
completely crazy right now with no
repercussions the moderators on twitch
and YouTube are deputized to stop hate
speech personal attacks anti-semitism
all of that stuff the banhammer is free
to use it's Super Tuesday and they are
deputized to use it but to be clear
political disagreements are welcome in
our soup in our chat rooms conservatism
is welcome even libertarianism as crazy
as that sounds is welcome but it's got
to be it's got to be respectful that's
that's the way that that we're running
things here okay a few other people that
I want to thank I don't want to get too
far off track
crystal mackensen's is new member number
10 tonight and that gets us to 10% of
our goal let me say thank you and
welcome to Garrett Hampton who is new
member number 11 today Daniel shellin
Barger is new member number 12
Stephanie Orban or or BA
is new member number 13 and Alex Civic
is new member number 14 now Alex I think
I recognize Alex civic from a prior
stream I don't know if Alex Civic now
maybe we have to Alex civics as members
or maybe alex is uh getting a second
membership who knows okay over on Twitch
I want to say thank you to Berger the
man for subscribing with prime brdf our
DSN for the subscription tan man has
subscribes subscribed as has Seth Equis
and Gazzara
as well as trooper one a not so unique
username has subscribed shrimp scampi
welcome gazer pug lop Xin I already
thanked Xin okay for people on Twitch
who may be interested or on YouTube
Steven Kenneth destiny bunnell ii was
here in town over the weekend we went to
brunch
he ordered both can you imagine listen
to this kenneth ordered sausage and
bacon with his brunch you know how often
you order for people who eat pork you
can get it you have a choice of sausage
or bacon and sometimes there's even a
vegetarian option Kenneth said I want
bacon as my choice plus a side of
sausage it was crazy and then we took a
picture after and it's on my Instagram
so please make sure that you're
following me on instagram at a David
Pakman a lot of people stunned that I am
taller than Kenneth and that you know is
probably a story for another day
okay as the numbers continue to roll in
here in a number of states that are what
we would consider in play let me read
some other super chats as they come in
if you have a question comment send it
via super chat on YouTube and it'll show
up in the lower left of the screen
Sasquatch hunter says boo de jedge used
to see Bernie as an idol yeah if you
look at the Budaj edge videos from 2018
it sounds like he's totally on board
with Bernie he got focus-grouped into
changing some of those positions sailor
avon says it saddens me to see fellow
burn
attack you in Sam cedar for pushing back
on the more conspiratorial claims some
on our side make I appreciate that
Cody Rudd watching Trump get elected
convention equals Trump win I guess you
mean contested convention Carl yes Carl
says the most similar swing to the Joe
Mendham has to be Clinton in 92 didn't
win a single primary or caucus until
Super Tuesday you may have to go that
far back yeah
uh sorry that this just scrolled up when
a bunch of super chats come in at once
it just starts scrolling Bob to 25-ish
says voting for Trump if Biden is the 20
top 20 nominee I don't give a [ __ ] I
feel that the DNC has done more damage
to our democracy conspiring against
Bernie it's insidious well a vote for
Trump will certainly be a vote for Trump
Paula barrows says go Bernie go Biden's
momentum is depressing hi from Amherst
Massachusetts
Paul Benke says why is Warren still in
doesn't she want Bernie it's not clear
to me it's not clear to me whatsoever
by the way Paula what's going on with
the old Rayo spot I was in Amherst a
couple weeks ago and when I went to
UMass I would always go to the old Rao's
location on Kellogg it then became cher
coffee cher coffee moved out and now it
looks closed it says like cafe but it's
not been open anytime that I've been
there recently it's very depressing
tristin mcoppins says if Biden is the
nominee might as well congratulate Trump
on his 2021 let me let me address that
issue okay I have a tweet about this
from a couple days ago where I said I
get a lot of people who contact me and
say David my candidate is the only one
that can beat Trump I hear it from Tulsi
fans and from Andrew yang gangers I hear
it from people who say if Bernie's the
nominee we definitely can't beat Trump
others who say Bernie's the only guy who
can beat Trump if you want to just get
my honest take on that I don't think
it's like that at all I think that the
top-tier candidates which in this case
are Bernie and Biden
I think they either both could beat
Trump or both could lose to Trump based
on
is the primary process and convention
process self-destructive is the
perception of the economy good the
perception of the economy good if it is
both will have trouble beating Trump it
is going to be very difficult in the key
states to justify replacing the
president when people feel the economy
is good this is not my opinion this is
history
okay on the other hand if the economy is
poor if the coronavirus reaction is
looking disastrous as it may either of
them could beat Donald Trump I don't
believe any of this there is only one
person that can beat Trump stuff I just
don't believe it if you disagree with me
you know let me know via super chat okay
let's get an update on how things are
going let maybe every 50 actually you
know what will reset at 8:30 we'll do a
reset like every 15 minutes roughly let
me thank a few other people over on
Twitch I want to say thank you to San
daaru for for the subscription on my
website I want to say thank you to who
do I want to say thank you to Carol gosh
Carol I am gushing with praise thank you
you are new member number 15 I want to
say thanks to Cody killing BEC who is
new member number 16 and Rasmus Sorensen
is new member number 17
tonight if you're just joining us and
don't know what the hell I'm talking
about we have it's sort of a friendly
wager I guess going where I believe we
can get 100 new members during tonight's
stream at join pakman.com and a lot of
people don't believe that including some
in my own staff as depressing as that is
so you can grab a membership at join
pakman.com the memberships do support
all of this extra stuff we do like the
live streams as the results continue to
come in other super chats here let's see
here
Drew's ayah says [ __ ] here Louisiana
okay Elizabeth Warren has become more
sickening to me than basically any other
candidate my question is how do the
delegates get split up if and when
Warren drops out delegates are not
automatically released they basically
stay with the candidate and then at the
invention things can be done is more or
less the answer
Davide then throne' says when are you
coming back to Montreal love the show um
maybe in the spring I tend to go to
Montreal around Memorial Day
although kovat 19 may change them Matt
Stone says do you get anxious about the
results or do you keep a level head you
seem to have a healthy emotional
detachment when Bernie goes down or up
in the results listen all I can do is do
my show tell people what I think vote
and you know be here with you guys in
tall in the same situation interpreting
the results and that you know I try to
limit my worry to the things I can
control and what I can control right now
is this stream basically AC zero five
ten says what is Biden over performing
today mean for the rest of the race it
means it's good for Biden essentially
and we're gonna look at some of those
numbers soon Mike Nico Bambino says it's
almost like Democrats are trying to
throw the election Biden doesn't have a
snowball's chance in hell against Trump
again I think that the economy's bad
Bernie and Biden are both likely to beat
Trump I think if the economy is good
both are likely to lose that that's the
way I see it and a lot of people are
very angry with me for that name
withheld says do not underestimate
Corona Chan
we may not make it to November angel
Hernandez should Bernie drop out if he
doesn't win if he doesn't win what I
mean he's gonna be it's gonna be close
tonight if we get an updated delegate
count right now you can get this just by
typing into Google 20/20 Democratic
primary delegate count we have Joe Biden
with 157 and Bernie at 91 Bloomberg has
picked up his first delegates he now has
six delegates Tulsi has a delegate I
have to apologize okay
I said last week Tulsi doesn't have a
path to a single delegate that was wrong
she had a path to a single delegate and
for that I apologize to you guys
Elizabeth Warren no delegates as of yet
in what we have seen so far okay as the
results continue to come in we are
keeping an eye on them and we
gonna do a reset of the numbers
momentarily here keeping an eye on the
PBS stream as well as the Washington
Post stream so far
Whitney's system says who do you think
would win in a fist fight between jenk
and Alex Jones well Alex Jones takes all
those supplements which he probably
believes would be great for him in a
fight but you know I don't know I don't
know about that Jay I'm worried a little
bit about Jenks health because he works
so much that he may not be in his best
shape right now so I don't know I think
I would take 2013 Genk over Alex Jones
I don't know how Jenks doing now between
TYT stuff in his campaign it's uh it's
it's tough he's doing a lot of work my
friends a lot a lot of work let me say
thank you to Jake Brooks Jake Brooks his
new member number 18 tonight at join
pakman.com website memberships of course
are the best way to support these
streams it's cheap it's easy its quick
and we have this outrageous coupon code
20/20 now which will save you 66 percent
and everybody who signs up at join
pakman.com gets a thank you today other
super chats coming in Dennis clump says
from Netherlands oh wait sorry I skipped
one I apologize
Brian I wrote joe says you think Warren
is staying and only to deny Bernie the
nomination doesn't seem like she would
win the super delegates anyway why else
would she stay could be because she's
part of the idea the goal of denying
Bernie the nomination it also could be
because she wants some negotiating clout
at some later point in this entire thing
Dennis clump says from Netherlands saw
youth turnout shame on you Alex Sotelo
no Waller is me says 2016 again Biden
playing the part of Hillary and Bernie
playing Bernie any Studies on 2016 loss
of young voters from primary to general
election if there are I haven't seen
those studies Bayesian Cronin says
Bernie wins
Warren to drop and announce VP Eric says
why don't Bernie call himself Social
Democrat I've argued that he should and
I've argued it for a while we have
numbers from Texas coming in and on that
note we should do a full check in on
everything that has happened tonight let
me refresh the Politico dashboard if you
want to follow along with me that is
where we are looking what has happened
so far Alabama has been called for Joe
Biden Joe Biden very much over
performing the polling currently plus 51
in Alabama Virginia Biden was polling
plus 17 currently with 92 percent
reporting plus 31 that is a signal that
is an important signal Bloomberg 18% in
Alabama 17.6 in North Carolina he is
picking up delegates here North Carolina
called for Joe Biden although his margin
of lead right now is much smaller than
the polling Biden was polling what was
it in North Carolina let me take a look
here Biden was polling plus 13 in North
Carolina and as you can see here Biden
only actually plus 6.7 in North Carolina
Vermont for Bernie as expected
easily we do have one percent of the
vote in in Massachusetts and it is going
to be a fight with only 1% in it does
not look like Elizabeth Warren will win
her home state although that 1% could be
from weak Warren areas it is right now
much too early to call but a fight
between Joe Biden in the first column
and Bernie Sanders in the second
Tennessee we have 1% reporting and it is
a three-way fight between Biden Bernie
and Michael Bloomberg Oklahoma with 2%
in is also a three-way fight although
five points almost six now separate
Biden from Bloomberg and in Maine Bernie
Sanders is yellow what does yellow mean
Bernie Oh Bernie's leading but it has
not yet been called right Bernie leading
slightly in Maine and then I was told it
looked like we started getting some
Texas information
and polls don't close until 10 let's see
if we have ah there we go we do have
some early data from some other states
let me just refresh Politico to see if
they're giving us any of that data they
are not so we'll check that out over on
the New York Times in Texas we have
early results and Bernie Sanders is plus
13 there with a small percentage counted
in Oklahoma under one percent reporting
almost irrelevant but Biden and
Bloomberg are in a fight with Bernie a
little bit further behind and then in
Alabama oh we already talked about
Alabama okay Texas is a very interesting
one and again these are just initial
results they mean very very little but
that is going to be an interesting one
to watch California is the biggest prize
followed by Texas followed I believe by
North Carolina and then is it
Massachusetts that has 99 I'm going from
memory here but we're going to continue
tracking all of these results for you
and nothing else called so far very good
Michael Bloomberg saying something let's
take a listen black black is the one
I've been talking with voters and my
message is simple I am running to beat
Donald Trump
and to start rebuilding our country and
to start getting things done
and I mean big important things like
stopping gun violence and fighting
climate change and finally achieving
affordable health coverage for all
Americans
you know Rico water light well
miniskirts this is a campaign for change
a campaign for sanity for honesty a
campaign for inclusion compassion
competence and a campaign for human
decency
and this is a campaign to bring our
country back together and put the united
back in the United States of America
that's the message I've been delivering
not only to Democrats but also to swing
voters who will actually decide who will
be our next president
and tonight we've proved something very
important we proved we can win the
voters who will decide the general
election and isn't that what this is all
about now well my fellow candidates
spent a whole year focusing on the first
four states
I was out campaigning against Donald
Trump in the States where the election
will actually be decided like Wisconsin
and Michigan and Pittsburgh and Ohio and
North Carolina
and of course Florida President Obama
proved that a Democrat can win all of
those states but in 2016 we lost them
all well I'm running to win them back
and together we're going to get it done
now we all know Trump's strategy attack
Democrats make the plans look
unrealistic unaffordable and undoable
that won't work against us our plans are
sensible workable and achievable and we
have the record and the resources to
defeat Trump in swing states the
Democrats lost in 2016 like Florida I
know we can do it and you know who else
knows it Donald Trump and that's why he
keeps attacking us on Twitter today he's
sent a tweet out urging people not to
vote for us gee I wonder why clearly
Trump is scared stiff of facing us and
for good reason in every campaign I ran
for mayor we built a broad coalition
that brought Democrats and independents
and moderate Republicans together Donald
Trump the other day called me short I
said Donald where I come from we measure
people from the neck up
that's how we're gonna beat Donald Trump
I believe we need a litter letter leader
who is ready to be commander-in-chief
not college debater in chief so if you
want someone who talks Turkey and who
has a record of accomplishment on all
the big issues facing our country and
who has the resources to beat Trump I'm
your guy all right well we'll see if he
pulls any significant number of
Delegates tonight we'll keep it on Mike
Bloomberg while I continue to tell you
about other things that are going on let
me say a few twitch thank yous to Mike
Rowe active part a cool wave and element
10 thank you all of you for your support
over on YouTube via super chat get your
super chats in and I will address them
Anna Burgos says David why aren't
Republicans running against Trump I mean
a couple tried and it didn't really go
well Bob Simon Says moderator blocked
Bob Robertson in error it's my real
YouTube account I had to make this
account to send super chat I'm a big fan
David please help ok please unblock Bob
Robertson moderators thank you
Makenna roads when are you going back on
Joe Rogan's podcast that's a very good
question and I am not yet saying let me
put it that way
Nick DiPasquale says I'm a New Yorker
living abroad in the EU my parents watch
Fox News and believe the coronavirus is
a hoax how do we address the global
pandemic together that's a pretty big
matzo ball or the people who straight-up
believe it's a hoax and I don't have the
answer today but we will certainly
continue discussing that this week Casey
Bates says how soon will we get a Biden
Sanders debate that would be an
interesting one big Pro says I'd like to
think Pakman and Kyle kolinsky for the
great coverage but it's time to gear for
Sanders not winning the nomination or
even a plurality ELISA
helgesen has grabbed the YouTube
subscription up that thing happened
where the they scroll down because of
all the super chats that come in as a
carisi right says do you think a Bernie
nomination would affect the down ballot
any differently than a Biden nomination
I'm sure although slicing and
exactly how is difficult to do Julius
Kashyap ski says what can Bernie do to
increase his chances get more votes I
mean listen it's pretty late in the game
now and momentum breeds momentum and
he's got up he's got to get some so
let's look at Texas if Texas do we have
anything else in Texas yet so with five
percent reporting Joe has gone ahead in
Texas but just marginally Bernie's got
to do something in Texas remember that
the polling going in in Texas was
Sanders plus five but then Biden plus
two more recently Bernie on average
winning by one point five he needs
margin he needs margin in the big states
in Texas and we don't yet have anything
in California and he's gonna he needs to
start grabbing delegates somewhere and
it's it's you know easier said than done
for sure
Clint sparks says thanks for what you do
David Ben cat says Bernie and Warren are
significantly different I'm voting
Warren because I like her better
although I'd ultimately prefer Bernie
over Biden what are your thoughts these
are the exact calculations that people
are making all the time it seems like
you have it pretty clear makeshift
altruist says what do people genuinely
like or think Biden will do to help
people or do they see him actually
beating Trump depends who you ask in
South Carolina I believe they see him as
doing good things I think that there are
people who in the last 48 hours with the
exits of Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar believe that it's Biden who
can beat Trump and not Bernie and they
again as I've said I think either or
neither could beat Trump depending on
the state of the economy the coronavirus
response and the the perception of
responsibility let's take a look at some
of the updates here that are coming in
it poll results we can also projected
Joe Biden will win Alabama with 52
delegates at stake
that's another call based on exit poll
results earlier tonight we projected Joe
Biden winning Virginia with 99 delegates
at stake
Bernie Sanders is doing well in his home
state of Vermont tonight where he is
projected to win and Vermont has 16
delegates at at stake well at this hour
polls in Arkansas are closed that state
has 31 pledged delegates up for grabs
and polls in Colorado and Minnesota will
close in under a half hour let's check
in now with our election insights team
led by them very good so the results
continued to come in and we are
continuing to follow them let me get
caught up on thanking people I don't
want to fall behind here let me say a
huge thank you to Brian blueness
the reason I say it that way is Boone s
is a street in my home city of Buenos
Aires in Argentina Brian I don't know
how you pronounce your name but I like
it a Stephanie Ramos is new member
number 20 tonight
Tiffany Sykes is new member number 21
tonight I also want to say thank you to
Martin Horace Co who is new member
number 22 this evening Stefan hoody or
load is new member number 23 tonight
Sean chair is new member number 24
tonight I want to say thanks to Hanna
Gibbs new member number 25 as well as
Robin Robeson or Robinson misspelled but
I'm gonna assume you spelled it
correctly Robin Robin Robeson is new
member number 26 thank you so much we do
have a goal tonight of 100 new members
the coupon code is there it's 2020 now
and it saves you a 66% off of the
membership of your choice super chats
continue to come in and I welcome them
any questions or comments for me please
do send them in I also want to say
thanks to Dre 33 for cheering a thousand
bits on Twitch would the message love
you Deepak
thank you I appreciate the support also
thanks to stone 500 for the sub I miss
doc so I watched you for the sub-element
ten has subscribed as well I think I
might have thanked element 10 already
ash a nurse says you previously hinted
at a possible upcoming tour any new
details maybe a book release maybe a
phoenix top
I have upcoming possibilities about a
tour but no details yet no book release
Phoenix top is on the table
Timothy s says your volume is a little
low soft and what has been the most
surprising Super Tuesday data to be
released so far ok let me let me up my
volume a little bit let me know if
that's any better most surprising super
day at Super Tuesday data so far it's
some of these margins quite frankly so
Biden winning you know by nearly 50 in
Alabama by 31 in Virginia that is
surprising the North Carolina numbers
he's actually underperforming and
otherwise those are really the only
surprising numbers so far in
Massachusetts Elizabeth Warren has now
taken a lead barely beating Bernie
Sanders with Joe Biden down to 25%
that's a shift I think where
Massachusetts is so different in
Massachusetts you've got this is a state
I'm familiar with Massachusetts you've
got the Berkshires okay they vote one
way I would guess the Berkshires are
more either Biden or Warren than Bernie
you've got the four one that well no
it's actually all four one three I
regard you've got the Pioneer Valley
area places like North Hampton and
Amherst which are very very liberal and
probably or more Bernie places would be
my guess you've got the central
Massachusetts area including Worcester
and Fitchburg and places like that which
are more working-class and a little more
conservative you then have the Boston
area you've got the North suburbs the
south suburbs and Metro West Cape Cod my
guess is Cape Cod they're big kind of
like Kennedy Democrats maybe would be
more like Biden folks you then have
going south towards Rhode Island which
is different the the different parts of
Massachusetts are so different that we
can see the Massachusetts numbers really
fluctuate throughout the evening and
we'll see ultimately what what what
comes of them alright let's go oh it's
our friend is this Dave Weigel I believe
this is my buddy Dave Rygel the party
they're voting for somebody else right
now so watching that and a cut in terms
of the delegate count
i watching warren hittin some affluent
areas but nowhere else have having them
troubled massachusetts it's really that
race to the top I think the Sanders
people were so focused on California
they and so I think unwilling to believe
that Biden could put together Hillary
style numbers of black voters that they
might fall into literally the same trap
they did in 2016
except worse because a lot of people who
do not who hated Hillary Clinton do not
hate Joe Biden alright I am getting word
that Texas has now reported twenty
percent twenty percent
I still see nine here from the New York
Times let's see if we have updated
numbers still seeing nine but I'm told
Bernie as ahead when it's 20 Oklahoma we
have Biden ahead with two percent
Arkansas we have Biden ahead with under
one percent
Tennessee has Bernie now ahead and what
is effectively a three-way race very
interesting we were following the
Massachusetts numbers we are following
the main numbers as well and a bit of a
different cadence between the New York
Times numbers as you can see here and
the Politico numbers different but as
you can see right now in the states that
are in play there are or things been
moved around okay so people of so there
are four different leaders right now you
have Biden leading Arkansas and Oklahoma
Burnie leading Maine Bloomberg leading
Tennessee and Warren now leading her
home state of Massachusetts but just
barely barely barely with only three
point six percent reporting at this
particular point in time
PBS seems to be talking to people
somewhere where it is still daylight out
and the Washington Post coverage with
our buddy day I hope that is Dave Weigel
if it's not it's so hugely embarrassing
hello to everybody who is just joining
me we have been here since the results
started coming in welcome if you're
watching on YouTube if you're watching
on twitch I have just some humble
demands for you very very humble demands
I want to first of all say thank you and
welcome to everybody who has subscribed
via twitch prime follow my channel on
twitch if you can I would really
appreciate that if you're watching on
YouTube please give my stream a like we
saw last stream the more likes we get
the more YouTube recommends our stream
and thus the more viewers we get so
please hit that like button there's
5,000 people watching and only 700 likes
and also please do hit that subscribe
button that really does help us and
these streams have been a great source
of growing our channel and if you just
came across us by chance I really would
I humbly ask for you to hit that
subscribe button if even one out of five
of you are not current subscribers that
still could be a thousand new
subscribers for us instantly and I
really do appreciate everybody support
let's listen to a little bit more of
Dave Dave Weigel's analysis here and see
what else is going on we are expecting
more results in just 14 minutes
yeah and that is a state it's honestly
the reason it was attractive to
Bloomberg folks is that this is the
first time it's had a competitive
primary without a Clinton running just
wanted outright easily in 2018 choices
team there was no favorite this time and
Sanders seems to be doing very very
early there's not much exit poll there's
no exit polling really but I did there
that there wasn't any groundswell for
Sanders I point out my story that
Bloomberg had an office in downtown
Little Rock two stories tall tons of
merchandise Sanders was working out of a
community center a couple blocks away
with the door that didn't work was there
was been locked out they were trying to
let me in and the door wouldn't work so
he did not have extensive organization
he had in other states and what you're
seeing tonight with by the strength in
in some cleave in some very dramatic
ways there are states like Alabama where
he did not visit he visit some over the
weekend I should say or like Oklahoma he
did not visit you to have campaign
office did not have a history of winning
there and just all these Democratic
voters we're talking about came out and
said I heard that he's the one who can
win I know him from the how many years
fine interestingly it does look at least
according to these numbers that Biden's
lead in North Carolina is expanding a
bit that was a place where Biden was
underperforming the polling but it does
seem to be expanding at at this point in
time which which is interesting but
we're going to have to take the the
results sort of
total no one state will tell us
everything we need to know let me say
thank you and welcome to Angela Cruz who
is new member number 27 today I want to
say thanks to Christine Ellis who is new
member number 28 at join pakman.com
Kalyan Brooks is new member number 29
tonight and Alex Varney is new member
number 30 tonight consider yourself
invited to grab a membership at join
pakman.com we are targeting 100 new
members tonight membership is cheap it's
quick it directly supports these very
long streams we will be doing another
one one week from tonight as there are
more primaries upcoming and I'll say
something great about you and thank you
live on air what's better than that
let's see a few other questions as
they're coming in via super chat here
shiso lion dog says shout out from
Tallahassee Florida voted for Bernie by
mail asking everyone to send super chat
and shout out where you are from and how
you voted all right there you go send a
super chat tell me where you're from
and how you voted sailor Avon says are
there times where people can play you at
chess yes I do play against viewers in
chess sometimes not on Super Tuesday but
during the more casual streams I will
play against play chess against people
South Texas Rover says whoa can't
believe Packman remembered my name
Alex Civic now has two memberships one
year and one monthly yeah I've
remembered Alex you signed up during
another stream Miguel says Bernie will
win California I believe he likely will
the question is the margin if Bernie
wins California by five points I don't
know that it gives him the margin he
needs
if Bernie wins California by 15 or 20
now we're talking now we're talking so
it's gonna come down to the margin there
Dee Smitty last stream someone mentioned
this is the boxing match between you and
Ben Shapiro in April or May has not been
scheduled to my knowledge
Dinobot says I'm Canadian and I'm
getting depressed at the results so far
donated to the NDP to make myself feel
slightly better Aaron D how does this
affect Bernie these early numbers well
these are not great numbers for Bernie
for the most part Biden's over
performing the
in states that he's winning he's winning
by more than he was expected to other
than North Carolina people asking for
delegate math updates here are the
delegates as of right now Joe Biden at
162 Bernie Sanders at 96 Warren still at
8 Bloomberg at 6 and Tulsi 1 I am not
mentioning Budaj edge and Klobuchar
because they are out these are the
latest delegate numbers that we
currently have
Jeff Emma says hey you Bob 225 says
Texas closed hundred of polling sites in
Black Latino areas 542 closed compared
to 34 in wider areas this is why I won't
support the establishment mister RC the
dawn says Bernie lead in Texas would win
if no Warren shake my head that's only
if you assume all of Warren's support
would have gone to Bernie and I don't
know that that's the case
Bernie now has taken the lead in Texas
Joe Biden sticking with him but Bernie
building a bit of a lead there Michael
Bloomberg appearing viable there and
Elizabeth Warren currently not appearing
viable in Massachusetts Elizabeth Warren
has now taken the lead followed by Biden
and Bernie and we are following numbers
in Oklahoma Arkansas as well as
Tennessee and Maine where Joe Biden has
taken a lead in Maine that's interesting
widely expected to go to Bernie Sanders
but only 3% reporting it still may it's
still very very much May let's get an
update over on the Politico numbers and
see where things are looking actually
well it will update the numbers just
before the nine o'clock stuff let's
let's do that instead because I do have
a lot of other people looking to get in
on the action here let me say thanks to
be Hasson sin' who subscribed with prime
NAR Chon subscribed at tier 2 on Twitch
Johnny colors has subscribed with Prime
thank you very much let me say thank you
- oh no no other new members apologies I
thought I had somebody else to thank
there Khoda has retracted a message
James Buchi no says the corporate news
and dem candidates are coalescing to do
everything they can to get anyone but
Bernie and it feels so smug and
dishonest and I'm pissed
Adam is a Furley oh sorry
those uh when super chats all come in at
once it starts scrolling Adams our
Furley where was Adams - fertile e where
was there it is how much do you think
Mike is paying the people of the
audience right now yeah are all crowds
around Bloomberg paid James montalbano
says do you think that your usage of
trumps nicknames for people like
Bloomberg furthers to normalize the use
of those nicknames in political
discourse yes and I shouldn't do it
I just find many so funny because it's
just such an insane thing for a
president to be doing but it I shouldn't
I shouldn't do it because it does
normalize it I don't want to do that
Joby Gill feather says just tuned in
how's the night going so far pretty good
for Biden that's that's the news so far
justine dao an hour says can we all
agree Bloomberg is mr. burns incredible
TV Wow I sent in a super chat and you
didn't read it just wow how do you sleep
at night
don't answer that rhetorical question
again I I read multiple super chats by
incredible I don't believe I skipped any
I don't know Nicki no no's says on
Google Bernie up 7% up where I don't
know in which state Paula barrows David
I'll check the Rayo spot on Kellogg
Street and let you know on Twitter thank
you yeah I need I need some insight
daddy-longlegs says get Louis Motamedi
back big boost for TDPS
he's money baby Michel Roux Scottie says
David when you went to take a dump
Bloomberg called Pittsburgh a state I
want you to know and hope your bowels
are ok holy [ __ ] Sean O'Connell what up
Pakman jev 10% of North Carolina
Republican voters selected other than
Trump that's interesting Luis Torres is
a new member
Julie escape chefs key what can Bernie
do after Super Tuesday I think I've
pronounced julius's last name three
different ways well but at Bernie's
gonna need to just pick spots where he
thinks he can grow a lead and focus in
on them because Biden's likely to take
the south that's the reality I don't
know how Bernie takes the south after
Super Tuesday and that's going to be
that's gonna be an issue
Joey Cain says Biden's that Biden's rise
never would have happened if the media
responsibly covered his mental health
issues the media should responsibly
cover cover Donald Trump's dementia as
well that's the reality
interview on my channel from yesterday
with dr. Justin Frank about exactly that
issue
okay let's update the latest numbers and
I know that every website let's see I'm
getting a note here about some of the
other websites okay let's take a look at
what we've got so far we are awaiting
some results just four minutes from now
Alabama Virginia and North Carolina have
been called for Joseph R Biden Jr
Vermont has been called for Bernard
Sanders no surprises there the polls
being over performed by Biden in Alabama
and Virginia and just slightly
underperformed in North Carolina we now
have a number of states that are in play
that we are looking at Maine Oklahoma
and Arkansas Joe Biden is winning
Oklahoma has 30% reporting and Biden is
+10 that may soon be called for Joe
Biden these others are very close Maine
is closed between Biden and Bernie
Arkansas only has one point eight
percent so the numbers mean very little
and Tennessee is very very close with
10% we then now have Bernie Sanders
leading in Massachusetts with six
percent reporting but just barely
with Elizabeth Warren in a close third
place and in Texas with 20 percent
reporting Bernie has jumped out to plus
six that would be huge for Bernie
Sanders if you look at the Texas polling
there are two Reese let's look at all of
the polls if you look at recent polls
you have Biden plus two this morning
Sanders plus five Sanders plus four
sanders plus nine the average is Sanders
plus one
point five if indeed Burnie can hold a
lead like this plus six point five
that's big that is the exact I said what
Bernie needs tonight is to over perform
in California and over perform in Texas
or dick us as I like to call it and he's
doing it in Texas so far with twenty
percent reporting we are just minutes
from polls closing at the top of the
hour and we will see if anything new
happens at that point in time we have
the Washington Post stream up we have
PBS results showing us a variety of
different things although they seem sort
of behind and we're gonna keep an eye on
all of that let me say thank you over on
twitch to t man twenty rocks as well as
Apple Jacks for kaboom tastic has
grabbed the subscription wild HBS has
also subscribed if you're just joining
us it has been so far probably
unbalanced I would say it's been better
for Biden than Bernie
although bernie is right now over
performing in Texas which is the second
biggest delegate treasurer of the night
and we are expecting some additional
results starting two minutes from now at
the top of the hour there they are
actually talking about these different
regions I mentioned the purple region is
the Pioneer Valley and north area where
it is probably a Bernie exactly as I
said these other areas so far going to I
don't need is this the Biden color is
that what that is
Bloomberg winning and one in the those
wealthy west of Boston suburbs
interesting very very interesting let me
say thank you to a few new members I
want to say thanks to Yelena sindhu Cova
who is new member number 31 tonight
Moritz deBeer is new member number 32
tonight
Vincent Finley is new member number 33
tonight Moka Barra is new member number
34 tonight and that's it okay very good
we have 34 new members our goal is 100
and I invite you to grab them
mber ship at join pakman.com all right
we are about to what is this thing that
they're running at the top of the hour
every hour trade a lot of momentum for a
candidate who's more conservative who's
more mahadji's these are like little uh
like historical things Alabama called
for Joe Biden we already knew that the
main results continue to come in and I
believe that we are very close to
getting some of these nine p.m. let's
stay here because we are about to get
some presumably Colorado as well as
Minnesota results super chats continue
to come in and I will keep answering
them as they come in Bob Simon says Bob
Robertson still blocked please help
David Bob I'm unable to do anything
about that during the stream but if
moderators can unban Bob Robertson on
YouTube please do it please do it
stone the forbidden says if nominated
who would Biden pick as his VP no idea
heard a rumor of Kamala Harris Reva
25:10 has grabbed a YouTube membership
nicho Matteo Nico McKay in five says
David can you explain how they can call
wins at one to six percent reporting
exit polls exit polls are very accurate
and if the exit poll says someone won by
thirty or forty you can safely call you
can safely call the race in those
situations
William Helms debtor says vermin supreme
2020 Waller is me comparing Biden and
Trump's sanity is like comparing apples
to oranges I see what you did there
Dylan McConnell says Bernie will lose
Texas big voter suppression winning so
far winning so far sub theory says may I
know what website you're using so we've
got this is the Politico dashboard and
then we're also looking at the New York
Times dashboard they are sort of up
there updating some states earlier than
others and we are very soon here
expecting Colorado and Minnesota numbers
Minnesota will be very interesting
actually let's look look at the polling
in Minnesota Amy Klobuchar was doing
very well in Minnesota and as you can
see here she was polling 27 and 29
she dropped out and it flipped to Bernie
plus five I believe Minnesota will be
interesting because it's conceivable
that there is a an endorsement effect of
clos Bashar Oh
the only Silverado HD adds to the
legendary capabilities at the strongest
most advanced Silverados ever oh boy oh
it's right here stinking Eska and larger
oh my goodness hi Paul but I seriously
apologize about that that's that's
disgusting Oh
the point is I'm curious whether
Minnesota will go to Sanders +5 or
whether there is some follow-on momentum
effect here to be expected to be
expected and we will see about that
okay let's get an update 9 p.m. update
here almost an interesting state we're
at less than 10% reporting but we have a
significant number of votes enough that
we can start talking about themes that
we're seeing now there are 37 delegates
available and the thing that you can see
about Oklahoma that's so interesting
it's an absolute patchwork right we've
got some Sanders votes we've got some
Bloomberg votes up at the Panhandle
we even have some Warren votes she's
winning accounting right now which is
really intriguing because she's not
doing all that well nationally speaking
or in the other states that we've been
talking about but again part of the
theme of the night it's a big night for
Joe Biden and if you blur your eyes and
take a look here you're seeing a lot of
blue now the news is we have an awful
lot of votes left to go Oklahoma is
another one of those states where we see
a pronounced early vote from the more
rural areas in the state and we're gonna
expect to see more votes from those
urban areas later in the night we don't
have anything from places like Norman we
have very few votes in Oklahoma City and
Tulsa those are places where we're gonna
see probably more support for folks like
Bernie Sanders well I think in Tulsa it
might go for Tulsi the only other place
that I'm really interested to talk to
you about is we've got a few votes
available here in Arkansas the state has
31 delegates available and we're seeing
again a lot of strong Biden in the early
boat although up here in Fayetteville
we're seeing some Sanders strengths I
expect that he's gonna do pretty well in
Fort Smith as well and interestingly
rounding out the third place Michael
Bloomberg he's doing pretty well he's
even winning himself a County right now
Greene County it's far northeast it's
not very big but hey he's doing well
there that's what we
right now alright Jeremy so let's talk
about the big state of Texas lots of
delegates up for grabs what's happening
there you know Texas is a huge state and
I don't just say this because it makes
up a large amount of area it also has a
ton of delegates now we have very early
results in Texas we're missing a lot of
the big places in the state but there
are some interesting patterns already
emerging Sanders and Biden were
basically neck-and-neck in the state and
the polls leading up to tonight and it
looks like Sanders in the early vote is
doing a little bit better than Joe Biden
where him at about thirty percent of the
vote
he's doing really well in Austin which
is not at all surprising and he's doing
well on this in the suburbs a down yeah
the thing is this data is outdated
because they're talking about with less
than ten percent reporting but as we
already know we actually have wait five
percent reporting that's behind as well
okay on Politico with 20 percent
reporting it is plus 6 for Bernie
Sanders let's refresh and see I don't
know if this is refreshing automatically
ah it is not we now have new information
okay let's take a look here very good
so Alabama Virginia North Carolina
called for Joseph R Biden Jr a Vermont
called
for Bernie Sanders Maine it's for Biden
right now Oklahoma it's going for Biden
right now Arkansas is going for Biden
right now Tennessee why is this spanning
all the way across that's weird does
anybody know why that's happening that
must be some kind of glitch right I
should just refresh that huh no but it's
all the way across so I guess we don't
know what's happening in Tennessee I'm
guessing that this is Biden this is
Bernie
and this is Bloomberg yeah it's weirdly
stretching all the way across something
seems like possibly a CSS issue
happening here we have nothing yet out
of Colorado or Minnesota although those
are now in play and we are expecting
data soon and in Massachusetts it is now
once again a fight between Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders was a with Elizabeth
Warren back to third place Texas still
going in the direction of Bernie
although I don't like how this entire
format just went went haywire hopefully
they'll have that fixed for us
relatively soon yikes that is ugly that
is
looking let's answer some more super
chats and by all means I want to hear
from you one suggestion was send me a
super chat let me know where you voted
and for whom you voted or for who you
voted either way and lightened soy boy
says David when you go on the Joe Rogan
experience could or will you recommend
Stephen Kenneth Bunnell the second for a
future podcast interesting how routine
Damir Ian says when will the rest of the
states vote they're voting now
California closes in an hour and 54
minutes so unless you mean other states
altogether some on March 10th and
subsequent dates Harrison says also for
Tallahassee voting for Bernie in two
weeks
Matt Chavez can you do live
medicare-for-all math based on Bernie's
plan no and not right now Jordan Jensen
says Bernie Oklahoma Bernie Oklahoma all
right
Justine Dan our Dow an hour Washington
State voted for Bernie mr. RC the Don
Bernie a hundred and eighty-nine
thousand votes in Texas will get more
than Trump Evan Sutherland wire winners
being declared with one or two percent
exit polls already addressed that Miguel
Palacios make sure to check if your
ballot has been counted I'm in
California it said mine wasn't counted
due to a missed signature have to go in
in person to fix it mike litoris there
you go uh and it just scrolled past hold
on
where was that hold on a second here
there is does that mean Tulsi can be on
the next debate no Isaac Lewis Texas at
21% on Google clever to swear what's the
difference between a ride symbol and a
crash symbol can you demonstrate the
difference with your voice also
macho-man drum cover for Trump so the
ride cymbal you can actually ride and
it's often used in jazz implementations
and a good ride you can play three
different ways you can play the the end
you or you can crash a ride cymbal you
can play the bell or you can play sort
of like that middle area and a crash
cymbal you could ride a crash cymbal
maybe in some heavier applications but
why are we even talking
about this the real-life Channel says
Chris Matthews old show David Pakman
hardball Junie McGraw Michael Bloomberg
king of the American Samoa coin
collector 82 says establishment will
never let Bernie take it John Sebastian
Pinera says hey from Canada odds on
Bernie's chances I have no special
insight the latest estimates are Bernie
has a 10% shot of hitting the 50% plus
one before the convention Annika Patil
will you be a pro bernie contributor on
MSNBC now that chris matthews is gone
they want to invite me i'll gladly show
up mike kay says a positive note for
Bernie and his supporters tonight we
don't have to hear Chris Matthews
compared tonight to d-day yeah my
thoughts exactly
Kalyn Brooks hey David thoughts on
Cornel West extraordinarily compelling
speaker so I am speak live not that long
ago David hammer says have you
considered traveling to Scandinavia I've
been to Denmark I've been to Finland and
I always forget is Finn is Finland
Nordic but not Scandinavian or the other
way around I never remember and I would
love to go to Sweden and Norway very
very soon
WS Lewis the fourth says I did a
ten-dollar super chat during the debate
but you signed off before you got to it
can you shout out Walter and my son Arry
you
yes shout out to Walter and ere you
appreciate that very very much let's
thank a few other people before I fall
too far behind which angers a lot of
people I don't want that to happen let
me say a big thank you to Ryan Morrison
Ryan is new member number 35 tonight at
join pakman.com Charlie Milson is new
member number 36 tonight Andrew Patton
is new member number 37 tonight and
Michael Malone is new member number 38
tonight thank you very much I invite you
if you're just joining us we will be
here for the evening it's going to be a
long night with peace and love I humbly
invite you to grab a membership at join
pakman.com it's very
it's quick it's easy it's the most
direct way to support us but we have a
cool coupon code 20/20 now and we have a
target of 100 we are at 38 out of 100
we've done we've dealt with this part of
the bar and now we're sort of moving
over here let's get some updated numbers
if we can over from the politico data
and see what's happening in Texas Texas
now with a little bit more of the vote
in and a little bit of a bigger lead for
Bernie Sanders so so far the Texas
numbers are better than expected for
Bernie in Arkansas we see a fight with
four percent reporting Biden is up
slightly Tennessee Massachusetts and
Maine have Biden up for now and more
states have moved to the called column
we will get a Ellicott update
momentarily but to catch you up Joe
Biden has one Alabama with a plus 48
almost Virginia has been won by Joe
Biden by plus 30 Oklahoma has been won
by Biden currently plus 12 North
Carolina by Biden plus 10 that
underperforms the polls so Biden is
underperforming in some of these spots
Vermont and Colorado have been called
for Sanders Colorado must be such a
major Sanders win that based on the exit
polls they were able to call it we have
the first numbers from Minnesota these
are almost completely meaningless
because it is 0.1%
okay Biden's up 15 but it's 0.1% doesn't
tell us anything Tennessee it is
starting to become an important lead for
Biden as he is plus 6 with 23% much the
same way that Texas plus 6 for Bernie
with 23% is significant and but Maine
may be a fight to the end we will see
Massachusetts very interesting but with
10 percent reporting Elizabeth Warren in
her home state of Massachusetts here in
Massachusetts falling to a relatively
distant third place I believe if Warren
loses Massachusetts by 10 if these were
the results
I believe Warren is out
within 48 hours that's that that's where
I see things going updated numbers on
delegate math remember nineteen
ninety-one delegates are needed to win
the nomination let's zoom this thing in
a little bit if we can
there we go isn't that better beautiful
Joe Biden currently has a hundred and
seventy four delegates Bernie Sanders
112 Warren has picked up a few in his up
to 12 Michael Bloomberg has six
delegates and Tulsi Gabbard has grabbed
a delegate in American Samoa ami is
stuck at seven and Buddha judge at 26 as
they have already exited their
respective races and that is where we
are right now some exit polling data on
the screen which we will keep an eye on
as the evening continues let me say some
twitch thank-yous huge thank you on
twitch oh boy there are some brutal
usernames pilgrim to pimp has subscribed
with prime hex seeker has subscribed
with prime AC zero 510 has gifted
another two subscriptions tax the rich
has subscribed with prime and Morgan neg
has subscribed with prime as well thank
you very very much if you want to get a
question up on the screen super chat is
a beautiful way to do it super chats
that are coming in include one from
Angie L what happens to delegates after
someone drops out they're basically held
until the convention at which point they
can be released and there are
negotiations that take place gr says
Pakman its gr they have coverage but
they aren't onto it yet it's the
coverage Pakman think it over
subs sections not real-world words
Pakman no idea what you're talking about
Trenton Turner says if Bernie is on the
path to a weak plurality after this is
there any hope that the nomination will
not be stolen on the second ballot there
is some hope there is some hope let's
put it that way
Matt stone why is Biden performing so
well without having campaigned in a
Super Tuesday state in over a month
Burnie draws tens of thousands to
rallies compared to Biden's dozens this
is why rally size no matter who it is is
not the indicator of how people are
going to vote oh sorry about that let me
scroll back up mr. RC the dawn says
Colorado called for Bernie you need to
use Google yeah we saw that we saw
Colorado called for Bernie here as we
can see let's get an update of the
numbers Vermont and Colorado for Bernie
four states so far for Biden Minnesota
still very little information Tennessee
now with 30% and a seven-point lead for
Biden is becoming significant as I
mentioned before Texas now at 25% with
plus six for Bernie I would be shocked
if Texas ended up going for someone
other than Bernie at this point again
when it's 22 to 28 the delegates will be
split relatively evenly importantly if
indeed Michael Bloomberg has 19% in
Texas that is also going to hurt Bernie
in terms of the delegates that he gets
if more people are viable at thirteen
point three Warren may also be viable in
some districts and may be able to pick
up some support there Massachusetts
continues to build and not look good for
Elizabeth Warren that is another
important state that we are looking at
as well let me say a few other
thank-yous to folks who have signed up
on my website Tyler James is new member
number 39 tonight I want to say thank
you to Kenny Holtz who is new member
number 40 tonight James Calhoun is new
member number 41 and Christopher Harding
is new member number 42 thanks so much
guys I really appreciate it we have been
streaming I think everything but the
Nevada caucuses I was out of town for
Nevada we've been doing streams every
single night now if you're just joining
us on YouTube please smash that like
button I really would appreciate that we
we've been doing tests and when people
enter a stream and like it and hit the
subscribe button you
tube thinks holy [ __ ] this may be a
stream that we should suggest to people
and then way more people come in so
please do hit the like button and the
subscribe button both are very very much
appreciated it's free and it just takes
a second and if you're watching over on
Twitch make sure you're following my
channel as well we are trying to reach
30,000 followers over on Twitch let's
see here Bridget Harding says voted for
Bernie in California
Miguel Palacios says voted for Bernie in
Orange County California
Jordan Jenson Gordon is Poorna Jensen is
pronounced Jensen okay big fans oh thank
you gore murat says do you honestly
think there's any hope for Bernie after
tonight yes there is hope we need to
follow this to the end the last 48 hours
really turned me off to the political
process I'm pretty disgusted I
understand that trust me I understand
that but there is hope and we've got to
play it through to the end
Michael Norman's has voted in
Springfield Massachusetts for Bernie
very mixed vote voting of mixed voting
here art Flores says Bernie for Los
Angeles County California
Nick Tom can has signed up Brian
holidays a member Kalin Brooks says Reed
Shawn McFate spook the new rules of war
I interviewed Shawn McFate about it John
the fourth says odds Warren endorses by
t boy once she drops I think it's a
two-thirds chance
Warren endorses Biden Joe Rader head
says Joe reader says hey David you
missed my wife Lee says new membership
oh did I hold on a second hold on a
second here Lisa let me see if I can
find Lisa Lisa Raydor there it is Lisa
Raydor is new member number 43 I
apologize not trying to leave anybody
out on the action and while we're here
I'll say thank you to David Graham whose
new member number 44 Mike Hernandez is
new member number 45 and we are we are
getting dangerously close to half
way which is completely crazy completely
crazy ws Lewis the fourth says ha re you
says thanks by the way I was first in
line at my polling station to vote for
Bernie at 7:00 a.m. today in Killeen
Texas
Justine Gowen our says do believe that
Warren not dropping out an endorsing
Bernie combined with her choice of
attacks in Beart on Bernie is hurting
her and her progressive base also do you
think she should drop out and endorse
him well I don't know that she would
endorse him if she drops out that's that
that's the the missing piece here and
assuming that she would is potentially
very dangerous let's see what updated
numbers we have as the numbers now are
starting to come in relatively quickly
okay uh let's see Minnesota no valuable
information yet Maine it's tight but
Biden slightly ahead Massachusetts
Elizabeth Warren is now 12 behind first
place in Massachusetts which is not good
for her
Biden is building what may soon be a
lead in Tennessee that gives him the
state Arkansas with 7% for Biden and
Bernie still very very solid in Texas
very very solid in Texas now where is uh
let's see Oklahoma has been called right
we already talked about that very good
okay let's see what's happening over
with the New York Times as data
continues to come in here in Colorado
which has been called for Bernie already
does look like a big lead for Bernie in
the initial results it has been called
for Bernie Sanders already Texas looking
like it is going in the direction of
Bernie Sanders as well Minnesota with
two percent reporting is plus nine for
Biden but that is early that is very
very early still and it could go either
way some of the new york times numbers
are ahead of Politico some of the new
york times numbers are behind the
politico numbers so we'll keep an eye on
on both as the evening continues over on
PBS no new results there to speak of but
we'll
with PBS at least for a little bit here
let me say thank you to parish ax0 for
subscribing on Twitch as well as jai ram
96 and death baloney death baloney has
subscribed thank you so much I
appreciate that
Thor Alfred Beck says did you see
Pascrell of the Ways and Means Committee
speak truth minuchin the manoosh might
be the least charismatic person alive
his snide and obtuse grin makes me want
to cry blood and drink bleach well don't
do that I don't I don't want you doing
that I didn't see it though GG H J says
debate progressive voice I don't even
know what that means
which progressive Bryan Holaday says why
do people like Biden I'm confused it is
confusing it is very very confusing I
I'm with you Joseph van Scoy says people
need to stop saying Bernie or bust
I voted Bernie but we cannot afford four
more years of Trump our planet cannot
afford four more years of Trump I agree
I agree with you my friend
Oppie says hey Pakman you feeling the
tull surge now that she picked up a
delegate yes I already apologized
tonight and said I made the assertion
that Tulsi did not have a path to a
single delegate and I was wrong she has
a path and has indeed secured a single
delegate as you can see here updated
delegate counts doesn't seem like this
has changed 174 to 112 Joe Biden Bernie
174 to 112 are the numbers as of right
now we are expecting more data to come
in between now and so at 10 p.m. in fact
let's look at that the schedule is that
at 10 p.m. Utah closes expected to go to
Bernie and at 11 p.m. California close
is expected to go to Bernie California
and the margin is basically what there
is to wait for tonight as these other
states continue to be counted depending
on the margin in California you could
see Joe Biden and the knight in the lead
or you could
Bernie Sanders and the knight in the
lead that's what it's going to come down
to in the end and I know many of you are
aware of that if you saw my segment
about this today let's see I'm getting a
report that the Texas numbers have
shrunk let's take a look at that there
is shrinkage not seeing it here so far
here it's still plus six for Bernie
let's see with the New York Times still
plus six for Bernie let's see if we can
find let's see if I type Texas
Democratic primary results what do we
have everybody right now is showing +6
for Bernie with four percent reporting
so if one someone wants to tell me where
that's going on I would be interested in
knowing about that but I'm not seeing
that RealClearPolitics okay let's see
popular vote oh wait now hold on a
second election 2020 Democratic popular
vote in Texas aren't you - sixteen
Sanders Biden Sanders up forty six
thousand look at the map Texas Sanders
twenty eight this is showing the same
thing as well
Bernie plus six so I I'm sorry guys I'm
just not seeing it oh it went from 25%
to 3% reported yeah that rights that is
very true we were much more reported
that is weird is that some kind of a
glitch that's very strange that is going
to raise questions there is no question
about that that is going to raise a
number of different questions let me say
thank you to a few other fine folks
Eric Briscoe is new member number 46
tonight thank you Eric Joey beat Cash is
new member number 47 tonight Emily
sûreté is new member number 48 tonight
appreciate that we are just two new
members away from 50 let's do a little
something okay I love giving stuff away
whoever is new member number 50 on my
website tonight
you get a free item from my online store
we've got coffee mugs t-shirts all sorts
of stuff okay so whoever is new member
fifty tonight at join pakman.com you can
use the coupon code or not use it
doesn't matter new member number 50 free
item will ship it anywhere in the world
that has reasonable you know package
delivery services I don't think we could
get something into North Korea but new
member number 50 tonight I will
personally handle getting you an item or
an item as some people say okay let's
continue with the super chats oh Malad
says GOP literally voting Biden Adam
Waddington says oh sorry Adam Waddington
says if there was a cap on add
circulation and funding do you think
Bernie would be in a better position and
would Bloomberg either even have
bothered no I mean Bloomberg would have
no shot at any state if you weren't
allowed to just buy ads and buy ads and
spend hundreds of millions of dollars no
question that's why it the system we
have is completely broken oh Malad says
republicans literally voting Biden again
okay
Carstens chronicle says some places in
austin report having to plus our lines
and that's my guess is that's a bernie
stronghold Junie McGraw says what does
jr. McGraw say I don't see any point for
Warren to continue after today I hope
she gets primary Dinh Massachusetts for
her vanity voted Bernie in Chicago yeah
please keep letting me know via super
chat where did you vote and who did you
vote for
Applejack's for says will we ever get
away from a two-party only system in the
US how can we do it two things need to
happen one fixed campaign finance to
some version of ranked choice voting
single transferable vote at all I guess
is what I would say both of those things
need to be fixed
amber Davidson has grabbed a youtube
subscription mani has grabbed a YouTube
subscription remember the offer for the
free item is for website memberships at
join pakman.com new members number a new
member number 50 will get a free item
from the david pakman show online store
david pakman
SlashGear oh boy and you know what the
website may have actually gone down
again because so many people are trying
to get a membership at once oh boy it is
get the website is just getting hammered
we're actually I'm gonna need to talk to
my webmaster and see if she wants to
update upgrade our hosting because it's
getting very very ugly there let's see
I'm gonna have to we're gonna have to do
a hard reset of the website I think
because it is getting extremely sluggish
from all of the people trying to get
that free loot from the David Pakman
show online store we're gonna do a quick
reboot of the website and it should be
back up and running before you know it
my friends before you know it okay
rondalee asks how do they reassign
delegates from the dropouts they're held
until the convention and then it's part
of the negotiation process they can be
released Jose says why are you denying
the toll mentum I know I'm terrible for
believing Tulsi has no chance Tara yeah
Tara says convinced a friend to not vote
Tulsi today because I showed him one of
your videos thank you my pleasure
Joseph van Scoy says really don't think
people realize the winner in 2020 will
likely pick at least one Supreme Court
justice if we lose then say hello to
Supreme Court justice Jeanine Pirro yeah
it's it's it could potentially get very
ugly
I see the messages from people saying
the website isn't is down I am doing a
hard reboot on the website to try to
clear the tubes for you guys I know
people are trying to sign up and get
that free loot so far it has not been
claimed new member number 50 gets the
free loot but the website is in the
process of resetting and it should be
reset very very soon
a user whose username is all numbers has
signed up Tyler James says recommend one
or more must read political books
I don't read political book so I
couldn't tell you I'm sorry any tips on
getting started learning chest yeah
Lee chess org and chess comm both have a
bunch of different free sort of like
basics start to learn
chess courses I would start there Aaron
Robbins says Irving Texas voted for
Bernie azim Abu Khalil says Fort Worth
Texas voted for Bernie a lot of Texas
we've so far heard from Killeen Irving
and Fort Worth folks who have voted
today for Bernie Sanders that is very
very interesting and let's see what the
latest numbers are here as they continue
to come in Texas now up to 6% and it is
plus six for Bernie Sanders Minnesota
starting to look ok for Joe Biden
something else has been called Oh
Tennessee has been called Tennessee has
now been called for Joe Biden as I
suggested it would the math now
insurmountable the question is what will
the split be Biden 35 Bernie 24 and
Elizabeth Warren no Bloomberg 20 while
Lizabeth Warren not even a factor let's
get updated delegate math if we can
website is back up by the way appreciate
everybody who stood by Joe Biden now up
to 192 delegates with Bernie Sanders at
122 Warren 12 Bloomberg 9 remember I
said by the time this is all said and
done Bloomberg will likely end up third
or fourth in delegates I still believe
that that may well be the case Michael
Bloomberg tonight is on track for more
delegates than Elizabeth Warren let's
take a look at it in the states that
have already been called well the states
that have already been called don't
matter because those were already in
those numbers in states that have not
yet been called you see Bloomberg viable
in Arkansas and doing very well in Texas
understand that if Bloomberg gets 19% in
Texas he will get almost as many
delegates out of Texas as Joseph R Biden
Jr Warren may get no delegates there at
all and then I guess that's that sort of
it so far Colorado will get Bloomberg
delegates Tennessee
North Carolina Oklahoma maybe at the
district level but by the end of the
night
Bloomberg may indeed have more delegates
than Elizabeth Warren and that will
certainly be a sight to behold so to
speak
okay I see a lot of people asking is the
free item still available it is so I
announced that new member number 50
would get a free item from my online
store so many people wanted the item
that it crashed the website I just
rebooted the website it's back up and
it's still on the table okay checking in
more folks here via super chat let me
make sure I don't miss any of these oh
okay okay
Roger Rivera voted in Los Angeles for
uncle Bernie vo bernie city guy USA
sends a super jet dan says all bernie
here in berkeley warren to drop soon she
may drop within within a day or two yeah
gregor killed al bernie in virginia was
like watching a democratic republican
split cities in college towns when
bernie everywhere else went biden ND
faithful 89 says voted in austin for
bernie
ruth Kaymer got a subscription kermit
Stanback says which candidates are most
likely to pack the supreme court
probably none probably none tyler
Sylvester I voted re early voted for
Bernie boy in Texas JC video plenty of
Christian US Christian conservatives
went to vote against Trump but we need a
pro-life dem want to vote against Trump
but we need a pro-life dem gonna be hard
to find one gonna be very hard to find
one in the latest numbers Maine has
swung back into the Bernie Sanders
column but just just just barely barely
barely barely we'll keep an eye on that
one that is an interesting race for sure
okay getting some kind of weird low
resolution video here from the
Washington Post let's see if we can see
if we can fix that we don't like that
low res video I don't anyway all right
good we're now now back and looking good
let me say thank you to folks signing up
with twitch Prime including crooks Minh
and oh that's it okay just kook's Minh
thank you very much okay
new member number 49 tonight is Kagan
Brian or Keegan Brian I'm sure how it's
pronounced that's new member number 49
that means that the next person to sign
up at join pakman.com gets a free item
from the david pakman show online store
if you've been waiting for that free
good stuff this is the time to do it
okay continuing on reading where people
voted and for who Adam boy Seth
Simonelli voted in East Falmouth mass
for Bernie City guy Centauri says go
vegan
who's vegan is that a first name or a
last name I didn't think they were on
the ballot
RJ Duarte says Magnolia Texas Bernie
2020 small town north of Houston
Rolando says why are people voting Biden
he stands for nothing Rolando adds why
are people voting Biden he stands for
nothing okay Coco Luna says voted in
North Carolina with friends hope Bernie
wins big I believe North Carolina has
already been big Lee called for Joe
Biden but could still win other places
nicolai says voted for Bernie in Tampa
Florida
t-man says if Bloomberg wins the general
election does he appoint Judge Judy
Bloomberg is not going to win the
general election his sous Nava Ritter
says thank you Adam boy says the
Politico site is better than Iowa's
election app yes it is it is much better
very much better okay and new member
number 50 tonight is oh no it's no
they're not in yet new member number 50
is still in play oh no Michael mace ok
Michael mace or Michael mcse that's
weird
Michael you are new member number 50
tonight you have earned the free item
from the David Pakman show online store
send me an email through my website
contact form join PAC david pakman.com
contact form lets you contact me ok we
are now only 23 minutes from Utah
closing and we may get some data there
let's actually see the New York Times
has been posting data even before states
close nothing out of Utah yet though
nothing out of Utah yeah let's see what
the latest numbers here are looking like
so far if you are just joining us let's
go through everything if you're just
joining us let's imagine you have not
been watching us for the last two hours
if you're just joining us Joe Biden has
won five states tonight
those are Alabama Virginia Oklahoma
North Carolina and Tennessee Bernie
Sanders has won Vermont and Colorado
let's just look at where the Colorado
polling was let me go back a little bit
here Colorado I have to search for it
Colorado Democratic primary Bernie was
winning every poll by as much as 14 and
Bernie is winning Colorado right now by
16 okay so Bernie slightly over
performing their five states for Joe two
states for Bernard from what is in play
right now we have Minnesota staying in
Biden's corner although not by much with
17% of the vote in we have uh that's
weird what is that not strange oh there
we go hold on a second I had the wrong
view up there it is I apologize for that
Maine is going back and forth between
Biden Oh something has just been called
hold on oh no it hasn't
okay sorry about that in Maine we are
going back and forth between a slight
lead for Bernie and a slight lead for
Biden in Massachusetts Elizabeth Warren
in her home state is falling further and
further behind now down almost 13 points
in Massachusetts and Joe Biden has built
a five-point lead here although it is
still early in Arkansas Joe Biden
currently has an 8 point lead with 10
reporting a Bloomberg almost doing
better than Bernie actually in Arkansas
my guess is if this lead stays around
20% this will probably be called for
Biden maybe 25% and then in Texas yes
with five percent reporting Bernie's
lead continuing to be right around six
percent right now it's five point nine
percent and a lot of things happening in
Texas Texas very very important for
Bernie Sanders the delegate count
updated now has Joe Biden extending his
delegate lead to 108 so understand that
the two numbers that matter at the end
of the night will be Biden's delegate
count and Bernie's delegate count that
will be determined by the margin in
California and the margin in Texas
primarily the margin in North Carolina
is already not looking good right Bernie
is down 13 to Joe Biden so in order to
make up this gap it's going to come down
to Bernie getting getting a ideally a
bigger win for him in Texas getting a
bigger than five or six-point win in
California we don't know what's going to
happen in California and Utah projected
to go to Bernie as far as I know but we
will continue tracking the exact numbers
by which that happens similar numbers
here from the Washington according to
the New York Times with 13% in
Massachusetts Biden is up six point
eight that is starting to become
significant that is starting to become
significant and in Texas with 10 percent
reporting Bernie plus six so I believe
it's looking more and more like Bernie
Sanders has Texas locked down and we'll
see if that changes but those numbers
looking better and better for Bernie
Sanders there okay welcome if you are
just joining us if you're watching me on
Twitch welcome make sure to follow the
twitch channel and consider yourself
invited to grab a twitch subscription if
you're joining me on YouTube this is so
important please like and subscribe to
my channel this stuff is free okay when
people like and subscribe we get an
influx of new view
because YouTube either gets tricked or
is rightly directed to suggest to people
this stream rather than other streams so
please hit that like button we are close
to three thousand likes on the YouTube
stream and certainly make sure you
subscribe we could if just a fraction of
you hit subscribe we could get to eight
hundred and twelve thousand subscribers
like that I mean just just like that you
know a few seconds anyway is what it
would take okay let's look at more
messages coming in via super chat
remember via super chat you can get your
questions up on the screen but if you
voted today
tell me via super chat where you voted
who you voted for that's what we want to
hear um let's see here where did I leave
off okay
Zachary Monroe says I voted early for
Bernie in Flagstaff is the journalism
minor a good pair with a political sign
major yes I'm thinking about becoming a
future independent journalist or even
aiming for the presidency in 2040 I do
want to tell you one thing though if
you're gonna work for yourself in and do
independent media the business skills
are actually really important to have a
lot of the other stuff you can learn by
doing it's good to know it but the
business side is good to have kwb says
just tuned in looks like things are
going well for Biden does this make a
contested convention more likely you
think yes it does bill a bowling says
why do people support Biden he's more
republican than democrat a fair question
for many many of his supporters brian
Fagin's so do you think tonight spells
the end for bernie not necessarily there
we've got it we've got to get all the
numbers in before we can say that
Rolando says David what would you do if
we kissed at the DNC Rolando I don't
know what the hell you're talking about
my friend Dylan Jersey attic says Corpus
Christi Texas voted for Bernie Lough
Neagh Vogler says my son and I both
voted Bernie Bernie and SoCal trying to
convince my daughter as well who is on
her way to the polls kai spooky says
vote
for Bernie in Utah little solace says
Modesto California senator Sanders vamos
Bernie vamos means let's go in Spanish
case you were wondering
AC says Latinos para Bernie Botha para
el Bernie and Phoenix Latinos for Bernie
voted for the Bernie in Phoenix dreaming
cat studio have subscribed keith voted
in Little Rock Arkansas for Bernie
Sanders a user I don't read Arabic but a
user whose name is in Arabic has signed
up I appreciate that
Corey Gorski says you advertise a serial
product as gmo-free
is this not pandering to conspiracy
theory like fluoride free with such a
pro sign space why not ask that
advertiser to omit that phrase I thought
we had omitted it from the ads I will
look into that I appreciate you bringing
that to my attention I will look into
that
Ryan Henry Dean says why does predict
that still have Biden winning Texas I
don't know nice guy Eddie says voted for
Bernie Monrovia California Latinos for
Bernie thank you okay let me thank a few
other people here we are now entering
folks we are one hour and 45 minutes
into the stream and we are now entering
the second half of our goal of 100 new
members you know when I said we were
going to try to get a hundred new
members on my website tonight they
laughed and they shouted and they cried
and they tried to beat me up and they
tried to crash my website but now that
we are within striking distance they're
not crying anymore Javier Alysia has
grabbed the fifty first membership
tonight diana bridget is new member
number 52 tonight Amar'e Ramos is new
member number 53 tonight Francisco cada
vez or got Ava's not sure how you
pronounce your last name is new member
number 54 tonight
Chazz club is new member number 55 we
are will you see 55
/ a 110 divided by 5 is to carry the
zero 55% of the way there
thank you thanks for sticking with me as
I did that math let's see here other
people David Jackman says says lay a
Stowe scene to ascend through Argentina
says read this without your Argentinian
accent I don't know how I don't know
that I don't even hear my Argentinian
accent it's weird epic fails says voted
in Portland Maine today they had run out
of democratic ballots at one point the
general feel was people were
overwhelmingly going Bernie Tyler Rabin
says voted for Bernie in Birmingham
Alabama
I don't didn't expect him to win here
but I was optimistic for a large young
voter turnout which didn't happen jaesi
video says have DP and ben shapiro ever
actually spoken or debated yes ben
shapiro has been on my program and we
have I mean it wasn't a formal debate of
any kind but certainly it was it was it
was spirited and let me put it that way
let's listen to what's happening here on
PBS and actually no they are not even
talking about what's going on let's
assume what's happening happening on the
Washington Post I'm gonna get a water
refill and then we will continue we are
at 12 minutes 12 minutes from Utah polls
closing what what's been really
interesting and I think we were talking
earlier about the difference between
backing someone who shares your ideology
versus who you think it's electable we
are seeing some of these states where
Democrats who are self identifying
that's very liberal still backing Biden
because they believe that Biden
ultimately can beat Trump and in the end
more so than Sanders and so it's really
interesting I would be really fascinated
to see if in the general what type of
platform buy it and puts forward that
could appease these voters a bit more
while keeping some of the conservative
more moderate voters we look at Nevada
and the turnout
Nevada and this energy that Bernie
Sanders was able to have there what do
you parse through there that that might
tie in to what you're hearing tonight
yeah so I would say the results of
Nevada showed that Bernie Sanders had a
lot of energy with the activist base but
the activist base is not the entirety of
the party and that's kind of what we're
seeing in the results tonight that a lot
of rank-and-file voters really do care
about electability of like Eugene and
James were saying and another
interesting sort of wrinkle in that is
that if you look at polling you can ask
the question a couple different ways and
it's hard to pin an exact number on it
but a lot of Democrats when given the
choice between going back to the
policies and approach of the Obama era
or moving to the left a lot of Democrats
do still choose the Obama era it's
oftentimes split there's a lot of people
in both camps so I'm thinking that Biden
is probably also benefitting from that
as much as Sanders has moved the party
in his direction we've heard about
Bernie Bros of course a term used to
describe Bernie supporters but here at
the Washington Post we caught up with
Bernie Sanders actual bro Larry Sanders
this is his brother and have you voted
today in the Democrats abroad global
primary listen to this distinctive voice
of his as he talked to our colleague
Carla Adam in London the risk of war
either from
a jerk like like Trump or from somebody
like Biden he's been caught up in this
whole American police the world thing
for decades I think that burn on his
outside of that piece understands he's
not a pastor but he practically speaking
sensible
and we don't need those horrible Bernie
Sanders brother who voted today it's
amazing because what that reflects is if
Joe Biden becomes the nominee if he
emerges out of this Bernie Sanders has
successfully painted him as a moderate
you know we kind of do it reflexively
now in fact Joe Biden is running on a
more liberal platform than Hillary
Clinton did four years ago but because
Bernie Sanders has moved the Overton
Window now we're kind of talking about
Biden as this moderate you know we're
hearing from Sanders his brother and
London and that's gonna be hard for
Republicans to undo in a general
election context because it's so now
kind of deeply ingrained that Biden is
like more you know to the middle than
Sanders and and that could end up
working to his advantage and we do see
at this this opening period for people
to be able to vote abroad so that is
also significant here as we watch that
happen over the next days let's go back
to our colleague Jeremy and the election
insights team now Jeremy I hear we're
getting some fresh results so what's
happening in Amy Klobuchar is home state
of Minnesota
you know Libby that's a really good
question this is one of those places
we've been watching tonight because as
Klobuchar dropped out of the race and
gave her support to Joe Biden we've been
looking to see if maybe Minnesota is one
of the places where we can see that
concrete actions start to take place and
we are seeing that a little bit in the
state of Minnesota so this is one of
those places where Biden is having
another pretty good night he's got about
35% of the vote with about 21% of the
vote in and we're looking at 75
delegates in the state of Minnesota now
Biden is not going to win all of those
he is still going to give up a handful
to Bernie Sanders more than a handful
really the truth is this is looking more
and more like a two candidate race
although we do have Elizabeth Warren
down here at 17% she's gonna be above
the delegate threshold which means she's
gonna get at least something out of
Minnesota now the thing that's a little
more difficult to say about this is even
if Biden holds on to win the state does
it really matter in a case where he wins
thirty five percent of the vote and
Bernie Sanders wins thirty three that
might be one delegate difference between
the two of them and that's just not that
much and that's one of those cases where
winning a state it doesn't really mean
that much in terms of the delegate math
Libby I'd love to get their response
here of James on that point that you're
making Jeremy James
even if the delegates are split that you
know state might get a big checkmark for
whoever gets the most delegates so even
if it's like you know very close call
they both walk away with a nice delegate
Hall it's that big checkmark so and so
is the winner and and that helps with
momentum right it helps with momentum
and it does help with the conversation
if you know it ultimately what matters
the most is delegates and you know in 20
in 2008 there were a bunch of nights
where we caught and on that note let's
get an updated delegate count as of
right now Joe Biden's lead 125 delegates
125 delegates delegates ahead of Bernie
Sanders as I have been predicting for a
very long time Michael Bloomberg now in
fourth place sort of third place from
the people still running in terms of
delegates you all know I said it a very
very long time ago and I don't think I
had any special insight it was just
pretty obvious that he was going to get
some delegates today and we are just
eight minutes eight minutes from more
results coming in a number of different
states Colorado called of course for
Bernie Sanders at this point in time the
Texas lead has now shrunk a little bit
but not an overwhelming amount still a
five point five percent lead for Bernie
Sanders and the situation in
Massachusetts is starting to get very
very real as Elizabeth Warren almost 14
points behind in her home state with Joe
Biden building a lead of six points as
the night has gone to 30 and now 31%
reporting and Biden still plus 6 plus 6
here in Massachusetts very very
interesting extremely interesting what
is going on here and disturbing to the
progressive movement no doubt let me say
thank you to nip Nick Tom Caen Nick is
new member number 56 tonight
brandy Sarah is new member number 57
tonight we are 57% of the way to 100 new
members if you're just joining us and
you don't know what on earth I'm talking
about just a little thing we call
membership
join pakman.com every time someone signs
up there the bar continues to fill up
and it is very very exciting stuff let
me get back over to super chat we are
going through super chats and people are
telling me where they voted and who they
voted for Lord or 1000 says I was the
very first to vote for Bernie in
Mecklenburg North Carolina I am
frightened to go to work tomorrow and
end up in a violent protest if Bernie
isn't it's well Bernie did not win North
Carolina that we do know Jackson says
Bernie may well be in a mate well maybe
an actual socialist at heart but if it's
doubtful he could get Medicare for all
passed how the hell could he make the
country socialist dumb yes it's
extremely dumb Lance Smith says I voted
for Bernie in Whittier California woo
Alex since Iraq says what's the most
awkward encounter you've had with a fan
someone who watches your show in real
life I don't want to say because they
could be watching there have been lots
of them John s says Biden breaking aap
says one Minnesota
I voted Bernie in Minnesota yeah it was
going that way let's get an update there
Minnesota now placed in the Biden column
yep and and interestingly enough I said
when it gets to roughly 20 percent if
the margin stays like this we may see it
called and indeed we did just
mathematically at that point based on
the percentage that would have to be
reversed for the remaining 80 percent
with every counted vote it becomes more
and more unlikely
so Minnesota now for Joe Biden but
remember with proportional apportionment
of delegates the difference between 36
and 32 percent may not be big
particularly with Elizabeth Warren
presumably viable there at 17.5% that is
very very interesting a very interesting
development as we are just five minutes
from data I love data starting to come
in in Utah so we're going to keep a very
very close eye on that as the numbers
continue
you two come in okay super chats others
Alexa Cameron says Warren is pulling
seven to 25% off
Bernie's back in every state if we use
their moderate math and add it together
then bernie is still winning that's if
her supporters would actually go to
Bernie I think it is a question mark I I
don't it's not obvious to me that that
would happen
Dinobot to says Biden winning Minnesota
makes sense due to Klobuchar R's
endorsement but leading Maine in
Massachusetts has to be a huge upset for
both yeah it is because Biden was not
supposed to win either
Dylan heart says Warren screwed over
Bernie I used to like her David McKay
has grabbed the YouTube subscription
Dylan Hart says again EE Warren screwed
over Bernie I used to like her Patrick
says Warren has no excuse to be still in
she has shown her true colors and her
ego skeptic fence show Dave you lose you
will always lose I'm not in this thing I
don't know what you're talking about
it's weird let me say thanks to some
people over on Twitch breezy subscribed
with prime and says voted for Bernie
Southern California yeah if you voted
and you're watching on twitch you can
also include with your subscription
message where and who you voted for
grungy Dan grabbed a twitch prime sub
spooky donkey subscribed with prime air
tastic subscribed with prime champ wiki
subscribed with Kiwi not wiki champ Kiwi
and says serious voter suppression I
tried to vote in Toronto for Bernie but
the polls were closed that's sad how did
they not let you vote in Canada
embarrassing very very embarrassing
let's see here anon Aslam says how can
Bernie beat Trump if he can't beat Biden
well we'll see if he can beat Biden not
looking good right now Xander Gilbert
says do you think this day will go down
in history as the day the progressive
movement ended or it could be seen as
the day the progressive movement started
we don't know yet let's see
Susan B says voted for Bernie in
Anniston Alabama not all of us are
backward thanks Susan B I appreciate
that let me know via super chat where
you voted and who you voted for and
it'll pop up right on the screen JC
video says what if Bernie publicly
promised to make Warren his running mate
if she drops out would she take it would
they win they would never do that that
that they in if that's gonna happen
they're gonna talk about it beforehand
they're not just going to Bernie's not
gonna just publicly say it okay it is
the top of the hour almost and we are
very close very very close to our first
numbers from Utah very exciting
situation in Utah Bernie Sanders
expected to win there let's look at the
Utah polling Bernie Sanders in the
latest poll the only poll conducted this
month Bernie Sanders plus six in Utah
that will be an interesting one to track
note that both Warren and Bloomberg
potentially viable in Utah in addition
to Biden so it could end up being almost
a four-way split the polls they're close
in the next minute and we are very very
soon going to start getting data let's
see if we actually have anything not
quite yet the Massachusetts numbers are
continuing to just slightly go in Joe
Biden's favor so the important thing to
understand about these numbers are the
lead has grown for Biden from five to
five and a half etc as the count has
come in the count is now at thirty-four
percent and Biden's lead has grown to
six point three percent Utah is now on
the board and we will soon see vote
numbers starting to come in from Utah
the only other state left voting tonight
is California worth 415 delegates 415
delegates closing tonight at 11:00 p.m.
one hour from now if you're just joining
us welcome we are covering the Super
Tuesday results if your
watching on YouTube please make sure to
like our stream it really helps bring
people in in fact when I said please
like the stream it helps bring people in
we were at 4900 viewers we've now gotten
about 300 more viewers thanks to people
liking the stream and please hit the
subscribe button as well because we are
now within striking distance of 812
thousand YouTube subscribers very very
exciting stuff let's see who else people
voted for as we await the first Utah
numbers keeping an eye both on the new
york times information as well as
Politico and we will see if the
washington post stream starts to come in
with anything joe biden easily easily
winning tennessee easily winning north
carolina the the margin actually they're
growing to 16 the alabama margin
shrinking a little bit from where it was
although the race has been called about
a 30 point win in Virginia as we talked
about very early in the evening Tulsi
almost getting one percent of the vote
there is 0.9 let's see here other folks
checking in Joanna Corvinus says orc or
Venus we are one election away from a
7-2 conservative Supreme Court majority
if you are lgbtq+ this should terrify
you
45 must go no matter what you know I
agree with that Joanna Taylor Neil psyd
says what does Warren think her niche is
going to be now she's hated by both the
establishment and progressives by the
way voted Bernie in the berkshires I
don't I think she's trying to maybe get
herself some negotiating power I don't
really know
Gregory Bertrand says I feel like a lot
of these reactions to Warren are toxic
and would be different if she were a man
interesting caveat Ali says has voted
for Thea Bernie in Chicopee
Massachusetts love it I recently was in
Chicopee I went to Massey's seafood and
had some delicious fish tacos
Javier's has convinced my mom and sister
to vote for him as well in Chicopee and
Springfield
got my friends to vote in Westfield
Massachusetts beautiful salmon savior
says voted in Worcester Massachusetts
the home of Sam cedar for Bernie would
have voted for yang if he was still in
would accept Biden Biden everyone else
trash bloomberg is a comedian joanna
Corvinus says you got my core venus you
got my name right the second time
very good we are awaiting data from Utah
let me say thank you to Colin Fox who is
new member number 58 tonight as well as
John Cole who is new member number 59
tonight James glue yes is new member
number 60 tonight Fabiola Quesada is new
member number 61 tonight Daniel McCabe
is new member number 62 tonight
appreciate that thanks to all of you we
are almost two-thirds of the way to our
target of 100 new members tonight let's
see if we have any Utah numbers coming
in we do with 28% reporting Bernard
Sanders jumps to a big lead in Utah with
33% of the vote Biden as of right now
not even viable in Utah that is good for
Bernie because the polling did have
Biden as likely viable in Utah as of
right now the the delegates in Utah only
29 would be roughly split not evenly
split but they would be split between
Bernie Bloomberg and Warren in the
second third and fourth columns on your
screen respectively as of right now
Biden would likely get 0 delegates
unless he has that 15% viability in some
district because these are it is at the
district level that you have to be
viable okay if you are watching on
twitch if you are one of the 1500 people
watching on Twitch
we have the rare opportunity right now
called a hype train there is an
exclusive
short amount of time during which we can
work through hype trains level one
through five
this is your time twitch if you've been
waiting this is your time I'm talking
about you guys that is exactly right but
in the mean time these are very bad
numbers for Joe Biden quite frankly and
the numbers in Texas not getting any
better Bernie holding for Biden the
numbers getting good for it for Bernie
holding a six percentage point lead
Bloomberg at 19 percent Warren at 13%
I believe Massachusetts may soon be
called for Joe Biden as 37 percent of
the vote is now counted Joe Biden's lead
has grown to six point three percent
it's been trickling trickling trickling
all the way up and off my camera shop
Wow things are getting crazy on Twitch
we're already at hype train level 3
that's wild
how did that things are moving quick my
friends things are moving very very
quick let's see if we have some updated
Utah numbers the new york times still
doesn't have them Politico does so we
will stick with Politico for the time
being
okay people continuing to check in on
super chat where did you vote and for
whom did you vote a Chad Williams says
David did you covered from sedition to
sudafed the signs are insane I've talked
about it not everybody agrees with that
analysis but I have talked about it Rony
Hearns has grabbed a youtube
subscription Thank You kwb says you say
data with the same emphasis as Trump
when he says China yeah angel Hernandez
waiting to be new member number 69 all
right if people want angel to be new
member number 69 we need a few other
people to uh to grab a membership or two
things are going bonkers cuckoo for
cocoa puffs on twitch right now where we
have four minutes left to complete hype
train hype train level three and all
sorts of people are going crazy throwing
in let me thank ECG thousand Apple Jacks
Drake Harris exes or wish Schwimmer
twitch felon l-dub Dec Ned Joe Brogan T
Vic's lackeys monkey bags these names
are crazy master Amanda clevy only BUTT
STUFF veteran Ross Beck termit and who
else shoe
Ryan rego white I'm struggling with some
of these usernames I'm not going to lie
but I but I always do the best I can
people continuing to check in about
where they voted viperx one says voted
Bloomberg he's donated tons to Johns
Hopkins you are the only person so far
today who indicated that they voted for
Michael Bloomberg interesting Dominic
Richardson says if Bernie wins plurality
and DNC tries to steal it
will there be violence in Milwaukee I
don't know from what I've seen I can't
rule that out including from some of the
people that have been writing to me okay
user says hey David voted for Bernie in
Edmond Oklahoma took me far too long to
get membership love your work by the way
my name just means Michael the American
okay I believe that that's Arabic
Michael the American Ray 1708 says my
wife said if Bernie loses she will vote
for Trump in November wow that could be
grounds for a separation in some
relationships mr. Biskit says I will
send an additional $2 if you can say the
first line from rapper's delight'
from Grandmaster Flash and the Furious
Five always I don't remember the first
line
Timothy s says Dallas Texas Bernie bill
a bowling angel for 69 Rishi Gama Conda
says is burn hoping for big leads in
Texas in California to win tonight yes
that's what it's going to come down to
and in fact let's get a delegate update
friends we now have a situation and
again I tell you things as they are not
as I want them to be Joe Biden has
281 delegates Bernie has 168 this means
that Joe Biden is now defeating Bernie
Sanders in the delegate count by 113 we
still need to see what happens in Texas
and California ladies and gentlemen we
have completed hypetrain level 5 on
Twitch it's now all gravy let's listen
to Bernie their short-term profits are
not more by the way this is Levi Sanders
Bernie's son were friends on Facebook on
the Facebook's very interesting stuff
the corporate establishment we're taking
on the political establishment
but we're gonna win because the people
understand it is our campaign our
movement which is best positioned to
defeat Trump right
you cannot beat Trump with the same-old
same-old kind of politics what we need
is a new politics that brings
working-class people into our political
movement which brings young people into
our political movement
and which in November will create the
highest voter turnout in American
political history
so we're gonna be Trump because this
will become a contrast in ideas one of
us in this race led the opposition to
the war in Iraq you looking at indirect
fight an attack another candidate voted
for the war in Iraq
one of us has spent his entire life
fighting against cuts in Social Security
exploiting to expand Social Security
another candidate has been on the floor
of the Senate calling for cuts to Social
Security Medicare Medicaid and veterans
Bubba
one of us led the opposition to
disastrous trade agreements which cost
us millions of good-paying jobs and
that's me
and another candidate voted for
disastrous trade agreements
one of us stood up for consumers and
said we will not support a disastrous
bankruptcy bill and another candidate
represented the credit card companies
and voted for that disastrous bill Levi
almost started clapping for that one
that was not good we have two major
goals in front of us and they are
directly related first we must beat a
president who apparently has never read
the Constitution of the United States
a president who thinks we should be an
autocracy not a democracy
but second of all we need a movement and
our developing of movement a black white
Latino Native American Asian American
gay and straight
of people who are making it clear every
day they will not tolerate the grotesque
level of income and wealth inequality we
are experiencing we will not give tax
breaks to billionaires when a half a
million Americans sleep out of their
streets
we will not allow 49% of all new income
to go to the one present when half of
our people living paycheck-to-paycheck
now I don't know what's gonna happen
later tonight we're doing well in Texas
right now that's true
we won Colorado right
and I'm cautiously optimistic that later
in the evening we can win the largest
state in this country the state of
California gonna need to that's for sure
what happens if this campaign and I
don't know what will happen but if it
comes out to be a campaign in which we
have one candidate who is standing up
for the working class and the middle
class we're gonna win that election
increasingly the narrative of course is
its me or is Biden is the language here
another candidate who has received
contributions from at least sixty
billion ads we're going to win that
election
and if there is another candidate in the
race who is spending hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars we're
going to tell him in America
you cannot buy elections
so I am excited about where we are we
have come a long long way and I wanna
once again thank the great state of
Vermont and all of the people in the
state
not only for the victory you gave our
movement tonight but for the years and
years of love and support you ever given
me and my family those little water
spilled on spring the crowd down Vermont
Vermont from the bottom of our hearts
thank you all very much let's go on to
the White House thank you so listen I
don't know if I'm projecting my feelings
about things on to Bernie Sanders but
it's feeling as though this was Bernie
saying the things we're used to hearing
from him but I'm reading some deflation
into and I see the word deflation
actually now starting to show up in the
chat quite a bit I don't know if people
agree with me but I maybe it's me
projecting my sense of what's going on
on to Bernie but sensing some-some
deflation there I am being told that
some places have called Massachusetts
for Biden and again I have mentioned
that it any say if it hasn't been called
it's going to be called soon would be my
guess the lead now six point eight again
with almost every update in
Massachusetts the lead grows for Joe
Biden over Bernie Sanders in
Massachusetts that's ninety one
delegates it's not the biggest state of
the night but I think it is fourth we
have California and Texas which are by
far the biggest of course sorry about
that
California and Texas then we have North
Carolina Virginia okay and then
Massachusetts so I'm not sure a couple
people said Massachusetts had been
called for Biden but again it's going to
be a split it's going to be a split and
Bloomberg Bloomberg not not seeming
viable so far in the state of
Massachusetts let me say thank you and a
sincere and big thank you to Benjamin
wolf whose new member number 63
and Lewis Nash whose new member number
64
we are humbly trying to get to 100 new
members at join pakman.com we are 64% of
the way there
you're just joining us we are now
waiting only on the closing of
California at the top of the hour it is
1018 p.m. on the east and 718 p.m. in
the West and we will soon have some data
from California I don't know that we
will actually know the winner of
California until midnight or later
unless it is a blowout in one direction
or the other but we will soon have every
state closed and we are also starting to
see data come in from Utah which so far
is very very very favorable to Bernie
Sanders
let's get an updated delegate count the
delegate count for now at last check Joe
Biden was ahead by 113 Joe Biden is now
ahead by only 109 so that has tightened
up a little bit as the vote continues to
be counted Michael Bloomberg now 19
delegates over Warren with 17 and Tulsi
Gabbard did get a delegate tonight in
American Samoa that is where we are
right now very quickly this is becoming
a 2 candidate race I would expect
Elizabeth Warren to be exiting
relatively soon particularly given that
she's currently third in her home state
of Massachusetts that is certainly not
good for her very much
not good very bad in fact I would I
would venture to say ok we let's check
out some super chats if you vote in
today everybody can send super chats and
they'll show up on the screen but if you
voted today tell me via super chat where
you voted and for who
Elizabeth derby says voted Bernie and
Minnesota convinced some coworkers that
were undecided as well calling Illinois
family tomorrow for Bernie
Melvin oliveria says what is Warren's
plan she's messing everything up I have
no idea I wish I knew her plan I don't
know
Jimmy Calhoun says it's not Grandmaster
Flash it's Sugar Hill Gang North own
whoops NARTH own says can I vote in
California with a Washington driver's
license I have no idea you I don't know
the wall there Beth Hanks has signed up
on YouTube Caden Kimball says what's
your go-to fast-food chain
haven't been to a fast-food restaurant
in probably 15 17 years when I did go to
fast food places my go twos were the
spicy chicken sandwich at Wendy's these
items might not even exist anymore and
the crispy strip meal at KFC typically
with mashed potatoes and coleslaw that
KFC coleslaw was like drugs it was crazy
that stuff was good but I have not been
to a fast food chain in like 15 to 17
years
William Henning says why am i seeing ads
during the live stream the stream is
monetized so I guess that's why
Zachary Monroe says does Bernie have a
real chance to win California yes he
does he does he has a chance but he may
not we'll see
kwb says you will assimilate hashtag
Bloomberg NARTH own says I have a
Washington license I have live in
California can I vote here I have no
idea I got I don't know what the law is
there Chris B says voted Bernie in
California rational Enquirer says
election is over Obama secret
negotiations regularly scheduled program
will resume in November Sean O'Connell
says voted Bernie in Asheville North
Carolina
joana core vinous every time I see that
I almost think it's Johanna coronavirus
joannec or Venus Wendy's spicy chicken
still exists Baron Steuben hey Baron I
recognize you voted for Bernie and
Virginia feeling defeated after doing a
lot of outreach bob says love you David
even though our views differ California
Bernie Hawkins a christen greetings from
Russia
we will fix this one too yeah I'm sure
you will let's listen to Joe Biden and
dr. Jill Biden here
Oh bide inspired up someone's got to fix
that that's funny Biden is on fire oh
boy
goodness
I think he gets not such visits californ
a few other small states to come in this
campaign I will send Donald Trump a key
taking off join us those folks listen go
to Joe Biden comm signup volunteer
contribute if you can we need you we
want you and there's a place for this
campaign people are talking about a
revolution we started a movement we've
increased turnout the turnout turned up
at us that can deliver us to a level
where we can do extraordinary
extraordinary things look Oh Jen DS Bowl
who's ever seen Biden this fired up no
more surprise Billy access to hospitals
and rural areas that will as urban areas
access to care a bold vision we missed
billions of dollars defined and I
promise you
cures for cancer Alzheimer's and
diabetes standing up to a beating the
NRA the gun manufacturers
and leading the world and take on the
extra steps of that of climate change
I'm going to start probably joining an
outfit I helped put together the Paris
climate Accord country with education
will not depend on your zip code but the
triple funding for low-income school
districts providing raises for teachers
full-time school for three four five
years old they got a back them off of
that mic or something free Community
College Radhika dances every job the
21st century and significant reduction
in the cost of going to college and your
student debt if you volunteer you pay
nothing
folks we can do this
let's get some straight Wall Street
didn't build this country you built this
country a class built this country and
unions built the middle class
and the neighbors wake up from the
thread oh my god what does happen whoa
what what does that woman sends let
something die oh my god what is
happening here one of these signs let
derry-o are these vegans oh they were
hit by vegans Wow everybody clearly
shaken up by that many of you come from
it's where we raised the people they're
the reason why I'm running there's a
reason why I'm a Democrat in the first
place
wow what a nice who teach our kids look
who race into burning buildings to
protect other people who grow our food
build our cars pick up our garbage our
streets veterans dreamers single moms
and by the way every dreamer have hope
because I'm coming and you're not going
anywhere
and we're at a private pathway a pathway
for 11 million citizens if the other
guys voted for the I don't you get into
that I won't get going why smart
these are the people that been forgotten
I agree with you man look the people
Trump for God the people I will never
forgotten I will always remember folks
that's what we need an economy that
rewards work not just well reestablish
folk sorry I just everybody regardless
of their race their ethnicity whether
their gender their disabilities
economics that Democrats and publicly
depends every strength look like we did
in South Carolina like we get across
America today
the crowds playing him on that's what I
was so proud yesterday being embraced by
Amy gobo char we won Minnesota because
Amy global charm that's true now we're
doing well in Texas because of better
award and that's why that's why I was so
proud so incredibly proud to have me
repeats endorsement as well
there's a man of character intellect and
courage and by the way I was proud to be
endorsed by Jim Clyburn man he is
something else
look our campaign reflects the diversity
of this party in this nation and that's
how it should be because we need to
bring everybody along everybody we want
to nominate will beat Donald Trump but
also also keep the house
Bloomberg second they want a nominee
who's a Democrat a lifelong Democrat a
proud Democrat that's a Bernie attack
this all starts with the revival of
decency and honor and character Trump
has Flair has fanned the flames of hate
and sought to divide us he's insulted
demonized and actually just the way he
talks about people he has not a single
sense of empathy he doesn't have any
compassion no regard for the values that
made this country who we are not the way
you were raised by your moms and dads
that's hysterical he looks at honesty
and decency and respect and he views it
as a sign of weakness he doesn't believe
that we're the beacon to the world he
doesn't believe we're all part of
something bigger than ourselves that's
why I've said from the moment I
announced for this candidacy we
literally in the battle for the soul of
America folks Witte means u-19 America
not sewing see you 19m anger and hate we
got a beat Donald Trump but we will but
we can't become like him we can't have a
never-ending war between the parties we
did the president could fight but made
no make no mistake about I could fight
but look we need as badly as badly
someone who could heal look just look
what we did we passed Obamacare what
President Obama and I did saving the
American automobile industry what we did
to pass the Violence Against Women Act
and what that bus is not enough this is
just a start we need a president can
heal the country as well and that is
what I will do as your president I
promise you
it's about reliving delivering real
results for you your family in the
community it's not about me Jill or
Valerie it's about you it's about of
families it's a paraphrase the English
poet Robert Brown and he said our reach
should exceed our grasp and my reach
does exceed our grasp because there's no
doubt of my mind we can grasp whatever
we reach for ladies and gentlemen I
quoted an English poet but let me pull
the real poet now an Irish poet Seamus a
man who wrote a poem called accurate Roy
here's what he says and I believe this
to the bottom of my bean he said history
says don't hope on this side of the
grave but then once in a lifetime the
longed-for tidal wave of justice rises
up and hope and history rhyme we can
make hope and history rhyme because what
we say there's nothing we can't do well
this is about the future it's not about
the past about our children and our
grandchildren it's about leading this
country and leading the world once again
folks we just have to remember who we
are
my lord this is the United States of
America the pluggin start winding down
and once again fight for the proposition
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men and women are
created equal endowed by the creator
with certain inalienable rights we said
so often in school we don't realize how
profound it is we've never lived up to
those words but until this president
we've never walked away from it ladies
and gentlemen I believe with every fiber
of my being that's who we are
biden's on fire Rebecca we are a decent
brave resilient people we can believe
again but we are we are better than this
moment we are better than this president
so get back up and take back this
country
there's not a single thing we can't do
you mentioned
God protect our troops thank you thank
you thank you
Wow Wow I mean listen if you look at the
Bernie demeanor and the Biden demeanor
it's clear who sees themselves as the
winner and maybe not so much the winner
tonight although again we are still
waiting on the results in Texas and
California closing in 25 minutes and a
lot still to be determined but quite a
day quite a day for Joe Biden and from
the point of view of just being a
political observer have we ever seen in
a 72 or 96 hour reversal like this we've
got a race call here let's see could be
Massachusetts we're not ready to call
the race in Utah know is projecting that
Sanders will win Utah the Beehive State
now Utah has 29 delegates at stake
tonight we can also project that Joe
Biden will win Minnesota 75 delegates on
the line there let's go to our colleague
Jeremy Bauer's the election insights
team for more all right yep so as we as
we expected and certainly already saw
there goes Minnesota going purple for
Joe Biden with 38% of the vote that is
an over performance for Joe for sure
Bernie Sanders I believe was leading the
Minnesota polling Bernie was winning
indeed and then we are continuing to get
data from Texas and the lead has shrunk
for Bernie but it is still about four
percentage points it's clear this is it
for Elizabeth Warren oh sorry and I've
got there we go it's clear this is it
for Elizabeth Warren it doesn't look
like she will win any state including
her home state of Massachusetts I would
expect Massachusetts to be called for
Joe Biden soon soon the lead now for
Biden is 6.5 in Massachusetts it has
stayed steady from when we were at 8% of
the vote all the way up to and including
50% of the vote
all right let's do some housekeeping I
see people on both YouTube and twitch
complaining about moderators either
saying the moderators are doing too much
or the moderators are doing not enough
but the moderators are doing the best
they can they are
volunteer team of moderators if you want
to be a moderator get in touch with me
through my website contact form
I can't mod people during streams
there's about a hundred things going on
on my 15 different screens here so
please get in touch by email if you want
to be a mod on youtube send me a link to
your youtube profile if you want to be a
moderator on Twitch the same thing if
you want to be on both again the same
thing all of that stuff we will deal
with during the aftermath as we call it
on Twitch I want to say thanks to people
who have been signing up and sending
messages decadent ista says so sad that
we will lose again because of hillary
2.0 IE biden Aerith a Kazakh hodge says
much love David hope your country
doesn't [ __ ] the bed again Zeke law says
Biden will have to be like this 100% of
the time to even have a shot against
Trump
yes thanks also to Ville Fayed and
freedom man as well as chunky 420 and P
Q coyote and everybody else over there
on my website I want to say thank you to
Oh some of these are coming in as
duplicates Rainer Werner Fassbinder
Rainer Werner Fassbinder thank you for
signing up ley de Batali oh is new
member number 66 tonight if you can
believe that and Deborah ADA Cruz is new
member number 67 tonight I also want to
say thank you to Diana Bridget whose new
member number 68 angel Hernandez wanted
to be number 69 this would be the time
to sign up this would be the time to
sign up if you wanted that 69th
membership which I know is very
important if you are joining us just now
Joe Biden has won a bunch of states
Bernie Sanders has won a couple we are
now waiting for California to close at
the top of the hour just 22 minutes away
and it is anyone's guess whether we will
know very quickly who the winner is
there or whether it is going to take
some time but we are waiting on the
results there let me now
oh and if you're just joining us on
YouTube please this is my please clap
moment please hit like and subscribe
please hit like LIKE and subscribe we
put a lot of time into these streams and
one of the best things you can do to
help other people find them in YouTube's
algorithm is like and subscribe we're at
3700 likes I think we could easily get
to 5,000 likes and please please please
do hit that subscribe button that is
very very much important please clap
let's now go to super chats if you voted
today please let me know bye super chat
where you voted and who you voted for so
far we only had one Michael Bloomberg
voter who checked in with us let's see
here
we missed a bunch of these so I want to
make sure we get back where was I
and Diego California biden's fired up I
want to make sure I don't miss any okay
here we go
abstract painter says voted twice in
Florida
don't Lynn says Massachusetts Bernie
Jeremy Jensen voted rock a rock way
Rocca della Fuente Guerra Utah just
kidding Biden okay
incredible TV says crispy strip meal so
beta Johanna coronavirus says no last
name pronounced Corr Venus oh gods above
my ears get him in you effing Mike Alex
since Iraq says Biden's fired up think
Trump gave him a dural he seemed to be
on something
ey T PS when you have to make your Mike
ear rapey to sound excited you've lost
cinema pigeon says voted Bernie in
California
Tom interval says I voted Bernie San
Diego Lashon pain if I saw this Biden at
the debates I wouldn't hate him so much
Melvin oliveria someone gave Biden drugs
William Henning Biden has a terrible
microphone Chuck and 2x I just don't
understand why so many people are voting
against their own best interest it's
truly heartbreaking Ranch elder looks
like lots of people went to Joe 3
three-three oh you can get a membership
by the way at join Pakman four one four
four one one one four four eleven 444
and that's the place to grab those
memberships Ryan Anderson David can you
give us your best Howard Dean yeah I
don't know if I can do it let's say I'm
trying to think back to that fateful day
back in whatever year that was it was
sort of like we're gonna go to
Washington and Iowa and Florida and then
we're gonna go to Washington DC rah
something like that right someone
clipped that for me Adam does se
thoughts on Biden Bernie ticket in
either order you know it just feels
unlikely it feels very very unlikely
Susan Hepler says voted early in Mesa
Arizona for Bernie
elcome ego says think Biden will pick
corn pop to be his VP yeah maybe so lady
Marvin DUP quad says he's not gonna win
the White House ah
Jacob Sabula is Biden think he is like
Romney chosen one prophecy Biden DLC
Dems need to go scott rau success can
you imagine upper Trump versus upper
Biden or downer
geremy comfort hope Biden doesn't blow a
blood vessel sim1 Manson sent a super
chat newah matt says I hoped Biden would
be runner up now I fear Biden will be
runner up brutal Melvin oliveria winning
means u19 America lmao nest Leigh says
now both Bernie and Biden had vegan
stage invaders
Edwin Vega I hear what he's saying but I
don't feel it accelerator
I voted Bernie in Minnesota Biden is a
Hillary crap
Michael Orlando Joe Biden is finding it
hard to form sentences stun ever says I
will never vote for this idiot Bernie or
none that will help Trump he 916 David
get off your phone you're boring me
Applejack's for Biden took his Geritol
voted Bernie
California Eileen Burke what do you mean
by over performing relative to the polls
so what we mean by over performing let's
let's do a little if you're just joining
us if we look for example at North
Carolina in the polling Biden was plus
13 in North Carolina if we look at the
actual results Biden is plus 18 so Biden
over performed the polls in North
Carolina that's what we mean that's all
we mean there let's look at updated a
Massachusetts numbers in Massachusetts
now with 55% reporting Biden is still
holding a lead of 6.6 percent any second
that's got to be called I think it is
soon getting away from Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren embarrassingly coming
in third in her home state not good
Maine still very much in play very much
in play and we are just 15 minutes from
the close of California let's get
updated delegate numbers Joe Biden
holding a roughly hundred point a
hundred delegate lead over Bernie
currently 104 Michael Bloomberg is only
six delegates away from tying for third
place and he is already third from the
candidates running I told you guys and
people were furious with me when I said
a month and a half two months ago
Bloomberg will finish third or maybe
fourth people went absolutely bonkers
people people mailed me animal excrement
over that prediction and it looks like
it's going to happen Bloomberg is
already third of people still running
and he is all in in fourth if you
include Buda edge there so anyway things
are things are going crazy I'm kidding
about people mailing the excrement
though and by the way we I send someone
else to check our p.o box you think I'm
gonna be caught dead there myself
who knows if somebody would mail me that
stuff we'd thoughts has signed up with
twitch Prime Jimmy qual has signed up
with twitch prime wheel Poli has gifted
a subscription thank you very much I
appreciate that let me say thank you to
Lucas Beck Lucas
Veck is new number 69 and is there
anyone else to thank there no we are at
69 new members if you're just joining us
the target is 100 we can do this we can
do this unlike the results tonight where
you might vote and you don't see the
results with these memberships that join
pakman.com you sign up you will
literally see this blue bar start to
creep across the screen towards 100 new
members so I invite you to grab a
membership at join pakman.com very
exciting stuff ok a jacob Sabula cents a
super chad bill abilene oops
bill Epling said what did bill Ebeling
say gogo angel a user whose name is in
characters I can't read cent 1000 units
of a currency I'm not familiar with
without a message I don't know what to
tell you Stein ever says voted Bernie in
California today Biden sucks
Thomas Tom max says me curious could a
OC runner win the presidency in 2024 I
don't even think she'd be old enough
then right bob says nothing will
fundamentally change quote Joe Biden
2020 yes
Dallas says Crosby Texas voted for
Bernie Bob Simon I'm not gonna lie
tonight I feel discouraged sad Brandi
says if both California and Texas go
Bernie does he still have a chance yes
it's all about the margin all about the
margin c.b.c ofj says signed up for
membership a while ago but I haven't
heard my name
Courtney be voted Bernie I did mention a
Courtney let me see if I can find that
again Oh Courtney box oh I did not
mention Courtney box that gets us to 70
very good if other people have signed up
for memberships that I've missed please
do let me know also want to say thanks
to Ben Bateson Ben Bateson is new member
number 71 71 tonight flying robot voted
early in California for Barnard comic
Kate absentee Utah voter for Bernie
Ricardo Franco hey Dave do you think
Bernie's turnout
numbers blow a hole in his electability
argument I I don't think there's any
electability I don't think there's any
strong electability argument right now
if the economy's perceived as good and
Trump deals with Corona or if
coronavirus is dealt with and Trump
benefits from that and the DNC
potentially does self harm through this
primary process nobody's going to be
Trump if the economy is perceived as
poor if coronavirus is out of control
if the DNC does does not self inflict
damage during the primary process then
Bernie or Biden could win I've been
saying this for a while that's the
reality
captain Rama says Joe got the super
delegate endorsement two-for-one deal
Mayor P P but says why would
progressives vote for Trump over Biden I
have no idea I don't know why anyone
would do that
William borgers says I don't see Biden
getting less votes than Hillary Clinton
fewer votes who won the popular vote do
you see any Hillary voters that wouldn't
be Biden voters I see Hillary voters
that wouldn't be Bernie voters that's an
interesting analysis I haven't done and
it's one that we should think about but
again I don't think any of those
arguments fundamentally tell us what's
going to happen in this coming election
let's take a look at updated numbers
from Massachusetts the Massachusetts
numbers now nearly 60 percent in with a
six point eight lead for Biden just
slowly creeping up you will also notice
folks and this is not good news for
Barnard the Texas lead for Barnard has
shrunk to three point five this is the
smallest that Bernie's lead has been in
Texas the entire time that votes have
been counted if Texas ends up 28 to 25
with Bloomberg also viable the delegate
difference between Biden and Bernie will
be very small in terms of the raw
numbers this is math this is numbers
don't kill the messenger I'm just
telling you what is coming in you have
all the information I have and let's
let's in fact do a little bit of that
math right now math okay that's what
we're doing
let me pull up a calculator here and put
it up on the screen for you in a way
that we will all be able to sort of
partake so here's what matters let's
imagine only these three candidates are
viable right so the but the viable vote
would be 25 to 28 7 + 17 9 that gives us
71 point 8
if 71 point 8 is the total viable math
that means that 25 sorry hold on 25
point two divided by seventy one point
eight that would mean Biden gets thirty
five percent of the to twenty eight
delegates that's 80 and under this math
you would see twenty twenty eight point
seven divided by seventy one point eight
that's thirty nine percent times to
twenty eight Bernie would get ninety one
so if the numbers remain as they are
right now I hope people followed the
math math with me if the numbers stay as
they are they are now Bernie would have
11 more delegates roughly in Texas than
Biden he needs that in order to close
the gap the delegate gap because as you
see Maine is roughly split whether it's
Biden or Bernie won't really matter
they're roughly evenly split so Bernie
needs to close this gap which now sits
at 104 delegates if Bernie only closes
the gap by 11 out of Texas that means he
needs a big win in California to be even
with Biden by the end of the night
that's the math of it okay that that's
the math of it I'm just letting you know
the math let's see here okay a few other
people to thank let me thank Erin
Robbins who is new member number 72
tonight and that's it we are 28 guys I
think we can do this people laughed at
me at the start of the night when I said
we are going for a hundred members
tonight we're only 28 away we're only 28
members away a hope Blackwell has
grabbed at which Prime subscription and
says voted today in Northern California
and of course supported my man Bernie
also vidi liddie has subscribed with
twitch Prime as well thank you very much
if you're just joining us on Twitch make
sure to follow my twitch channel if
you're just joining us on Facebook
please like and subscribe we are at 4000
likes I believe we could get to 5,000
likes tonight that that might sound
crazy but I think it's conceivable that
we would be able to do it so make sure
to hit that like button and of course
hit the subscribe button as we are now
just 8 8 8 minutes away 8 minutes away
from the close of California California
closing very very soon let's look at
some other super chats chill stir says
think Biden would get Hillary in the
general it's quite possible died Ellis
says say yeah to our pups Donna and
Dexter hey Donna and Dexter you're both
very very good I hope you're enjoying
the show Bryan Holaday
your preparation for the variety of
topics topics you cover is amazing thank
you for your hard work
Thank You Bryan I appreciate your
support daddy longlegs Dave thoughts on
getting no Mickey Const on the show
maybe yeah we don't typically interview
just other like pundits we do usually
interview scientists academics
professors doctors etc people so I tend
not to have just other show hosts on my
show typically be and for no reason
other than my audience doesn't like it
the interviews always do terribly like
really really bad I can just play
voicemails and it'll do better than
interviewing other interviewing other
other sort of pundit commentator types
okay
g-money rider says massachusetts went to
biden i'm just tuning in if it didn't
yet it will very soon yes it looks like
it was called yep I mean listen guys I
hate to be the bearer of bad news but I
did call this 90 minutes ago and no no
surprise based on how the numbers were
going a Justin delegate count uh this
may not yet reflect Massachusetts but it
plus 105 for Joseph R Biden Jr over
Bernard Sanders and Michael Bloomberg
only five delegates away from formally
moving into third place
Bloomberg already in third place on the
basis of candidates that are still
running Massachusetts if you're just
joining us called
for Joseph R Biden Jr on the political
website
apparently not yet called by the New
York Times but certainly will be soon
and I want to get a look at those Texas
numbers okay so it's it's holding
roughly steady plus three point four for
Bernie Sanders in Texas and as we
calculated that we'll get that we'll get
Bernie about eleven more delegates out
of Texas
now I also do want to point out Tulsi
with one delegate is now within striking
distance of Joe Biden's three hundred
and twelve delegates if Tulsi can get
90% of the delegates in California she
is immediately and I mean immediately
folks right back in this thing so that's
certainly something - certainly
something to keep an eye on as we are
five minutes five minutes from the close
of California it looks like they are
maybe calling Massachusetts here
although it has already been called and
again there is not any chance that
Massachusetts goes any other way let me
say thank you to a few other fine folks
mark nee Hass is new member number 73
tonight thanks mark
Kat Quinn is new member number 74
tonight Charles Jacobs is new member
number 75
Jennifer retino is new member number 76
we are 24 away from 100 new members at
join pakman.com ok sim1 manson says are
you of the belief democrat or bust if
there was a Republican that was better
than a down
I would vote for the Republican based on
the Republican nominee being Trump and
based on the Democratic nominees that
are currently running any of the
Democrats currently running I would vote
for over Donald Trump yes
ey TPS says we still got two-thirds of
the states to go after this don't give
up
Dallas S has become a YouTube member t
class official says this is a terrible
day George Carlin was right
we don't have elections we have owners
the establishment has truly doomed us
all Bob Simon the only silver lining is
I have David Pakman coffee very nice
Peter curial sends a coffee mug of some
kind John Tyson California you're the
heroes
America needs we are three minutes away
from California closing city guy USA
Bloomberg should have primary Trump then
we'd know if he could beat Trump if he
couldn't there still would be another
chance with a Democrat the logic is not
totally sound there unfortunately
Chad Williamson has signed up on YouTube
sin for me what will the Democrats blame
this time when Biden loses Biden right
Michael Boyd says Elizabeth absolutely
spoiled Bernie primary her Elias Taylor
says thirteen sixty-seven delegates on
Super Tuesday right why doesn't it add
up you know I don't have the exact
numbers in front of me but it's
somewhere in the 1300 range Westin
Rasmussen voted for Bernie in Grand
Junction Colorado Bill Appling says wait
did angel get his spot no we we had
member memberships 69 come and go
without angel Hernandez don't know where
he went
Janny Gillette or Gillette and Molly Moe
have grabbed YouTube subscriptions
Ricardo Salas what do you think about
Bernie focusing more on social
capitalism instead of social democracy
do you think it would make a difference
on how the progressive movement is
perceived helping Bernie win more votes
well remember Bernie doesn't focus on
social democracy he says he's a
Democratic Socialist
kwb point taken kwb point taken
let's see if you stick to your word
quincy miguel's
bagel okay if Trump wins in November
what do you think happens to the
Democratic Party going forward any hope
of the two-party system crumbling the
two-party system is unlikely to crumble
just from a trump reelection but what I
have said is Trump winning re-election
in November is if he if he defeats a
centrist could be the best thing that
ever happens to the progressive movement
could be could be okay let's see where
we are Oklahoma we already know about we
are awaiting results in California
moments moments moments away angel
Hernandez says crap I was driving and I
don't think renewing counts right well
you know what angel you you influenced
some people and that really that matters
let me say thank you and welcome to new
member number 77 that is Jacob Mero
and new member number 78 is Sebastian
Lavigne or Lavigne depending on your
preferred pronunciation I also want to
say thank you to dr e d who is new
member number 79 we are just moments
folks from california california is now
on the board and very very soon we may
start to get results california polls
close at 11:00 let's see if we get any
data winning from california nothing yet
but very very soon i am keeping an
extremely close eye on the texas numbers
where bernie sanders had been up five or
six most of the night but now is only up
three and a half in texas that would be
plus minus ten delegates for Biden
versus Bernie in Texas that is a very
important one to look at let's refresh
and see California is live ladies and
gentlemen California is live we
not yet have any numbers out of
California but we may before you know it
updated delegate count Joe Biden plus
104 over Bernie Sanders Michael
Bloomberg about to officially move into
third place as I predicted months ago he
would be who cares okay anyway that's
going to happen as well but we are most
closely watching Texas as well as
California California has been called
for Bernie Sanders California has been
called for Bernie Sanders already
although we do not know the delegate
counts let's see if we hear anything
about that is anyone else calling
California unless this is an error
anybody know if this is an error I am
seeing California already called for
Bernie Sanders let's see what anybody
knows about that and people saying how
can they call it with 0% reporting if
they're calling it with 0% reporting
it's because he won big not a glitch not
a glitch California has been called for
Bernie Sanders this is the last hope ok
let's run some numbers all right let's
just start to run some numbers if
California ends up this is gonna be
interesting let's look at California
right now let me pull up my calculator
ok the first question is if California
is as polled ok let's just look at the
averages the three viable candidates are
Sanders Biden Warren they have a
combined 74 percent of the vote if
Bernie gets 35% of that he gets 47% of
the 416 delegates that gets Bernie 196
let's call it 197 okay
very good now if what was that number 73
if Joe Biden gets 25% of the vote he
ends up with roughly 142
that's only a 33 delegate difference
it's the the path is starting to close
the path is starting to close for Bernie
Sanders because if unless Bernie Sanders
dramatically over performs the polling
it is not going to be a big enough gap
to make up the difference that's that's
the unfortunate reality Bernie must over
perform the polls Texas is shrinking the
lead is shrinking it is now down to just
three point two so Bernie has to
drastically overperform California
let me uh-oh my stuff might actually be
fro there we go we're back I am going to
get a final water refill and then we are
going to look more closely at these
California numbers stay with me one of
the things that's really apparent from
taking a look at these vote flow
diagrams is that there are a ton of
people turning out tonight who did not
vote in the 2016 version of the
primaries both in North Carolina that
which you can see here and in Virginia
and these are places where Joe Biden did
very well and it appears that one of the
reasons why he did so well is that he's
pulling in a lot of this new vote these
are voters who had not previously voted
in 2016 and are voting in 2020 a bit of
the conventional wisdom there was that
if there was a high voter turnout that
those would be voters who would be
voting for Bernie Sanders so this has
actually been a little bit of a change
from what we expected and it's been an
unexpected area of Biden's strength back
to you Libby thanks so much Jeremy I'd
like to welcome my guest for this our
national political reporter James Holman
and Eugene Scott reporter for it the fix
so fascinating to hear what Jeremy was
telling us Eugene because it wasn't just
the the thought that Bernie Sanders
might be able to expand his coalition
and bring in those young voters it was a
goal of the campaign I mean it's
something that they have believed they
would be able to do and that it could be
key to building the Bernie Sanders of
the future the Bernie Sanders team of
the future
absolutely number one it's always
fascinating to hear that there were
people not involved in the 2016 election
because I feel like of almost everyone
we talked to had an opinion but the
reality is there where voters who were
still well people who weren't yet voters
who were on the sidelines who are
looking in
and the Bernie Sanders campaign made it
very clear that they were going to try
to get those people to turn out those
numbers haven't really worked in their
favor as much as they thought they would
have and it's been fascinating to hear
that they have worked in violence that's
not something that I was expecting but I
think what we do see with those new
voters is that they overwhelmingly don't
want trumpism to move forward and want
to get someone to the White House who
they believe can defeat him and when
they're looking at the landscape they
think that the former vice president has
a better chance of defeating the current
president so that's who they turned out
for James you have to look at Virginia
which puts these ideas into stark relief
and it's not Biden didn't have a ground
game but I didn't have the money to run
ads this is this is dislike for Donald
Trump we've seen it since the 2017 state
legislative elections in Virginia where
there was historic turnout in the
governor's race in the 2018 midterms
when Democrats picked up three
congressional seats in Virginia and then
tonight massive increases in sort of the
suburban counties where the backlash to
Trump has been strongest kind of
suburban college-educated women showing
up who weren't particularly active or
motivated in 2016 but really wanted to
feed Trump and for them our exit polls
show electability was the top concern
they want to beat Trump and so if they
care more about electability than
someone who agrees with him on all the
issues they were vastly more likely to
support Biden not because they
necessarily love Joe Biden but because
they hate Donald Trump so it is it does
undercut the whole theory of the case of
the Sanders campaign which was that they
were gonna expand the electorate his
Biden put it in a classic kind of Biden
malapropism turn out turned out and it
turned out for me the story of the night
and that he was he was able to kind of
ride this wave not because of his own
campaign or you know half a billion
dollar ground game but because of a
really organic backlash to the president
would you know which which is
manifesting itself
what could this a million dollars over
the bit you know he's representative but
the husband of the counsel to the
president Kellyanne Conway he tweeted a
screengrab of himself maxing out
to Biden I've actually heard from
various Democrats who kind of one
prominent Democrat texted me and said
Biden is Lazarus coming back from the
dead and and said he was giving money
and so I think you're gonna as we
continue to see the results from
California come in it has been called
for Bernie Sanders although we do not
know the percentages at this point in
time let me answer some other super
chats here let's see here where did I
leave off and mankiewicz or people okay
Matthew s says California allows
absentee voting at three days after
voting day if mailed on Election Day
same-day registration in person and many
counties with fewer polling centers
Chris M are people's fears have changed
due to thinking Bernie can't get things
passed through Congress or have they
been brainwashed by the establishment
narratives well there are reasonable
critiques of the of the pragmatic
realities of Bernie's policies that
doesn't necessarily mean you don't still
vote for the ideal and negotiate from
there I take issue I think with the
framing Jeremy Landry says Ben
mankiewicz in thinks Bernie is scary
what are your thoughts I'd have to see
what Ben says kwb says I owe you
98 bucks okay phylogeny says I live in a
San Diego community of over 60,000
people and two voting locations when I
voted there was only one other person
voting it was depressing that is
depressing
Daniel Brantley voted for Bernie from
Littleton Colorado
Dalbert lay all David I'm anxiously
awaiting Texas results after voting
Bernie
Brendan Klaus do you think Ruth Bader
Ginsburg can hold out till 2025 I don't
know the answer to that and that's why
Donald Trump has to be defeated over on
Twitch let me thanks say thank you to
machete F G money rider
J Snodgrass and true dark Meijin I also
want to thank new members Xavier de
Costa a Silva is new member number 80 of
the night whoops not
880 there we go Joe mama is new member
number 81 very clever
Dixon Rivera is new member number 82 and
I believe that's it yeah okay very good
I'm caught up
we are only 18 members away 18 members
away from hitting our goal updated
delegate counts Joe Biden is now plus
109 over Bernie Sanders and Michael
Bloomberg is a one delegate away from
tying Pete Budaj edge we have announced
that indeed California has been called
for Bernie Sanders as is on the screen
we do not yet have any voting data but
it must be such a big victory for Bernie
that they are comfortable calling it
let's see if Trump's been tweeting about
all this I'm kind of curious tweeting
about mini uh let's see here Elizabeth
pocahontas Warren other than mini Mike
was the loser of the night she didn't
even come close to winning her home
state of Massachusetts well now she can
sit back with her husband and have a
nice cold beer the biggest loser tonight
by far is mini Mike Bloomberg his
political consultants took him for a
ride 700 million washed down the drain
and he got nothing for it but the
nickname mini Mike and the complete
destruction of his reputation way to go
Mike what else has he been tweeting
Trump wins Arkansas Republican primary
can you imagine the winds continue it's
like he's not running against anyone
it's so such such idiocy from donates
his salary okay so not too much other
stuff actually related to what's going
on here is Trump talking to doctors okay
we don't need that all right so it's at
any point now we were expecting to get
some numbers starting to come in out of
California as I mentioned the we Bernie
needs to win California by a lot to make
up that margin it he has to win by a lot
because in Texas it's a small margin
Brendan fody says Rosie put your phone
down I don't know what that means
first-class admiral Gigot chad says
listen up chat jack and it's Biden time
ride or die Greek lamb says if Bernie
doesn't get the nomination could he run
independent and still win he could not
he would make sure Trump won though if
he did that Thomas Nelson what do you
think about sam cedars program redshift
and do you think that effects democratic
centrist candidates regarding electoral
manipulations I didn't see it I didn't
see it I apologize
Jason Harvey says who carries the
progressive torch in 2024 Joe Biden
can't beat Trump good question
Adrian benningfield is there a
possibility of vote rigging for Biden I
mean I have no particular reason to
think so
Paul molesky I know for a fact in
Oklahoma Republicans switched
registration to vote Biden to ensure
Bernie lost they want Biden versus Trump
I hope we get some reporting on that
Elias Taylor number of Delegates pledged
is less than the number of Delegates
available why uh I'm not seeing that
let's see declared needed pledged yeah
I'm not sure I you you're gonna have to
tell me exactly where to find the data
that you're looking at
Alex Drake has grabbed a youtube
membership flaccid donkey says David is
a big math sellout Thor bear Baalbek
says voted for Bernie in Fayetteville
Arkansas very interesting if you're
joining us on Twitch welcome if you're
watching on YouTube welcome and thank
you if you continue to watch on Facebook
it looks like the Facebook feed died for
some reason so I will actually formally
pinch off that stream and we will be
done with the Facebook stream for the
night it seems to be completely and
utterly dead de dee dead
Bloomberg ahead of Bernie in California
that doesn't sound right at all and
again it was called for Bernie so it
seems it is probably some early artifact
can anyone tell me if anybody has any
California vote counts reported so far
because we are still getting all zeroes
everywhere anybody have an idea where
can we get some actual California vote
counts hmm
Google all right let's see California
Democratic primary results okay very
interesting with one percent reporting
Bloomberg is technically winning by
about forty votes that's true all right
well we'll see how that continues to
develop let's see here Bernie also ran
says you read the president of the u.s.
calling Warren Pocahontas without any
surprises if it's normal that's the
world we live in sadly it is it's
extremely unfortunate but sadly it is
deaqon nine nine ninety five by how much
would Bernie have to win Kali in terms
of percentage to close the gap I don't
even know but I some very quick math
tells me that if Bernie doesn't get 65
percent in California I don't think he
closes the gap can you guys fact check
me on that I'm just it's very rough math
Bernie needs to beat Biden in Cali by
more than 25 percentage points yeah
right
exactly 65 cuz if by then other people
will have I mean if Budaj Edge and Biden
have roughly this amount it's got to be
big it's got to be very very big Patrick
Kelly asks why is there no room for the
second amendment in the Democratic Party
policy well there is in that the Second
Amendment exists and they're not trying
to repeal it
joana Corvina says Bernie or bust people
keep forgetting about judges Keanu
Fabiana says when asked about paying for
all policies why does Bernie pivot to
paying for Medicare for all instead
since he released a plan for it what's
the California victory math the
California big victory math has to be
big and right now bernie is plus seven
one percent reporting see if anybody
else has any data Politico nothing New
York Times nothing only Google has data
so far
ey TPS if you voted oh sorry if you
voted Biden you are an awful human being
I've met Biden voters who are not awful
human beings they just have different
priorities and priorities that are more
difficult to describe as actually
progressive that's Ryan Henry Dean New
York Times has Biden Bernie coin-flip in
Texas that would be a dagger let's see
the Texas numbers thirty-four percent
reporting plus three point six in Texas
here with twenty nine percent reporting
plus three it's gonna be close it's
gonna be very very close for sure JC
video would you rather see Trump's tax
records or medical records you know
there may not be honest medical records
to see so maybe taxes in a sense
Andrew borne says the david pakman show
one of the only sources i put my trust
in to give a genuinely honest take i
appreciate you man keep up the great
work thank you so much I appreciate you
and I also appreciate all of the great
people who have been grabbing
memberships on my web site tonight Alex
Parnell is the 83rd person to do so
Suzanne Slade is number 84 and we are
very quickly only 16 new members away
from 100 100 we are now finally getting
some numbers in from California a
California has already been called for
Bernie Sanders the only question is how
much is the margin of victory and is it
enough to do away with this margin as
you can see the delegate count right now
is plus 109 for Joe let me refresh still
109 for Joe
and the question is is it even
conceivable that Bernie wins California
by enough to close that gap and we don't
know the answer quite yet and ruru's
says at least America agrees poor corn
pop not porn pop corn pop was a bad dude
Mac says apparently Bloomberg to
reassess campaign tomorrow not shocking
Ben Bateson much appreciation from
Australia a Bernie win is the only way
real change can happen even for us over
the pond
thanks again Dave Brian bueno has
grabbed a YouTube membership Ryan Henry
Dean I mean New York Times live model
prediction live model prediction is that
live forecast let's see if we can find
that Texas is maybe Sanders okay yep
fair enough that seems about right
they've got the cumulative delegates at
how does this how are these numbers
right 631 631 but here it's 327 is this
making some assessments best gets
through kid delegate well I don't know
how they have these numbers these these
have not actually been awarded yet but
if this is the outcome Biden would end
up plus 25 56 Plus 56 Google now 6%
reporting with Bernie solidly in the
lead
Bernie plus 12 over Joe Biden in
California okay I mean that's something
that's something that'll keep the
numbers close for sure or Thep line it
says Business Insider website currently
shows Bernie at 28 Bloomberg 19 Biden 16
in California roughly what we have here
is Zek hempseed says Bernie loss plus
coronavirus hypes equal Camelback broke
hmm Keanu Fabiana says you forgot to
answer my policy question please do what
was the question
uh-uh why does Bernie pivot to paying
for Medicare for all since you released
a plan for it what's the company oh well
because some of the math for the other
programs is blur is fuzzy that that's
the reality that's why he does it
Dennis Klump says David your opinion on
this today has a lot of southern states
if Sanders a Social Democrat stays
within a hundred to Biden he has a shot
you know I was actually thinking the
opposite I was actually thinking because
of the states that are remaining other
than New York
if Bernie isn't winning by more than 50
I think he's in trouble but it really
could go either way it is very very
early still at this point in time and we
we have to wait and see let me say thank
you to Felix sky who is new member 85
tonight thanks Felix I appreciate that
if you're just joining us we've been
streaming here for nearly four hours we
have a majority of the results in at
this point in time Joe Biden has won
Alabama
Virginia Tennessee North Carolina
Oklahoma Arkansas Minnesota and
Massachusetts
Bernie has won Vermont Colorado Utah and
California has been called for him
although we have no idea what the margin
will be in play our main where they will
roughly split the 24 delegates with
Elizabeth Warren maybe grabbing a couple
Texas where Bernie Sanders currently
leads by three which are rough math
suggests would get him about a 10 or 11
close of delegate closing of the gap
Bernie would close in by about 11
delegates based on that math and then we
are watching the California numbers come
in if you're just joining us on YouTube
make sure to LIKE the stream and hit the
subscribe button if you voted today
send me a super chat telling me where
you voted and who you voted for
Rigoberta Munoz says did the DNC tell
Warren to stay in the race to sabotage
Bernie I have no idea I mean there's a
lot of assessments being made without
evidence and I want to avoid making them
mr. Gonzalez says I only trust David
Pakman to report voting results sets
aside bias keep up the great work thank
you James McCabe Bernie or bust people
equals eight
supporter Jennifer Senath says
California Plus Bernie over Bloomberg
not Biden Leonard Sorenson if Biden
seems possible at the moment does not
get the necessary 15% in California that
would be huge for Bernie right
it would although right now he's at
seventeen point four because I'm bat
stain has subscribed Jason Harvey says
let's hope Biden drops below 15% in Cali
that could happen it would be of a
massive underperformance Biden was
polling a 23 going in and he's not
underperformed anywhere by that amount
if I had to bet I think Biden is viable
in California if I had to bet magma 2400
I'm a registered Republican but these
sycophants that refuse to listen to
reason and common sense are too much is
it better for me to switch parties or
stay so I can be a voice of reason well
listen what you've got to do is vote for
someone other than Trump in November you
can be an either party to do that and
then figure out the rest later
jaesi video says how bad must Michael
Bloomberg do before he exits about as
badly as he's doing I mean I I again and
we just had an announcement that he's
going to reevaluate the campaign
tomorrow he may be out but by tomorrow
Roswell Salt Satterwhite says the people
have clearly spoken and it's Joe Biden
their voters still believe in centrism
and return to normalcy as the antidote
to Trump the numbers in California may
modify that assertion but we will see
mum in predator says voted for Vladimir
Putin in Paris France okay Walt Spence
has grabbed a youtube membership as well
thank you very much I appreciate that
let me say thank you on my website to
Nicolas bisetti who is new member number
86 we are getting down to the wire for
getting to our goal of 100 new members
so if you're just joining us or if
you've been here for a while consider
going to join Pakman
grabbing a membership the coupon code
2020 now will save you 66% and we plan
to continue streaming election results
including a week from tonight
March 10th numerous more primaries as
well as others coming up later in the
month
Taylor Neil psyd says is there a likely
path forward for Bernie after Super
Tuesday given these results mainstream
media will be back and by backing Biden
big time now huge boost for him I'm not
gonna lie to you it's an uphill battle
for Bernie after tonight if he can't get
very very close and even if he can it
may be a problem my assessment going in
was Bernie needs to be 40 or 50 ahead
4050 ahead because of the states that
are left to vote if Bernie is behind it
is an uphill battle it's nothing
nothing's impossible it is not
impossible but it would require a
momentum shift for sure 1:09 remaining
as the gap right now between Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders as Michael Bloomberg
has now formally tied Pete Budaj in
third place for delegates and I believe
ultimately he will be a solely in third
place you all know I've been saying that
for months at this point flying robot
says Monterey beat Bernie Sanders 28
Biden 22 Bloomberg 17 Warren 11 the
numbers from Monterey California okay
very very interesting numbers coming out
of there let's see what else is
happening here California discussion by
today Election Day your vote is going to
be counted and in a couple places that's
going to be going to be the real
difference between whether or not we
have you know a Joe Biden picking up a
handful of Delegates whether or not we
have you know someone like Mike
Bloomberg picking up a handful of
Delegates but that's essentially the
things we're going to be watching the
state of California for until then I'm
gonna kick it back to you Libya great
thank you so much Jeremy okay Eugene
looking at California and the
demographic breakdown of California it's
going to be such an important
state to watch not just in terms of the
delegate count and who gets the check
mark the win but also to see how turnout
is I mean and to really track why people
are voting the way that they are what
will you be watching for well looking at
turnout see how significant it is if at
all and where it goes right and so I
think the assumption yes very very
important to look at turnout as a proxy
indicator for maybe what is to come Joe
Biden with a little bit more of the vote
counted still at 17% and you know I
think Biden probably is viable there
Manny says there's also Florida to worry
about yeah I in Florida I think the last
I looked was not looking good for for
Bernie Sanders let's take a look at it
right now
the latest polling has Biden up 22 in
Florida you know I mean listen you never
want to you you never want to what am I
trying to say you've got to go out and
do it right we all know you've got to go
out and do it but if Bernie's not
winning after tonight and Florida is
even remotely like this it's very bad
it's very bad for Bernie Sanders there's
no doubt about it let me look at the New
York polls as well that's another 220
for Bernie according to the latest poll
which was two weeks ago was up in New
York but again this was with Buddha
judge and Klobuchar having 18 if Biden
gets just 9 of that he almost dies like
if Biden gets only half of Buddha judge
and half of Klobuchar
he gets up to where Bloomberg is Biden I
mean Bernie would get some of that as
well it's an uphill battle guys I mean
this is this is the reality nothing's
done but it is certainly an uphill
battle absolutely for sure let me
welcome some new people particularly I'm
talking about
ricardo gonzalez who is new member
number 87 tonight ricardo thank you I
appreciate your subscription so much we
are close to 100 new members tonight
over on YouTube
super chats are coming in Felix Kai says
Bernie supporter here but still
called Jo seeing lots of petulance and
rudeness from Biden's supporters towards
Bernie supporters what the hell is the
point since we are all on the same side
idiotic Vlad veksler says David do you
think Bernie's campaign articulated
strongly enough their electability
argument why Bernie can't beat Trump why
Bernie can beat Trump sorry listen both
sigh everybody always argues on
electability without explaining why that
that's the reality you never really get
good explanations because there aren't
any as I said before I believe many
Democrats could beat Trump if these
circumstances are correct I believe
every Democrat would struggle against
Trump
if the economy is perceived as good if
coronavirus is dealt with relatively
quickly which I hope it is no matter
what the political implications are
because it's absolutely horrible we are
that that is going to be a big factor
and who can win and I find the
black/white arguments of only this
candidate can win only that candidate
can win relatively fraught and I would
be concerned about hanging my hat on any
of those insidious vid says David are
you Bernie and busts terrible take in my
opinion no no no I'm not Bernie or bust
at all all of the Democratic candidates
running right now I would vote for over
Donald Trump I don't do stuff like
Democrat or bust because you could have
a race where the Republicans better than
the Democrat if you ask me am i voting
for Bernie over Trump yes am i voting
for Bloomberg over Trump yes and I'm
voting for Biden yes Warren yes you know
I would vote for any of the people that
are left here over Donald Trump for sure
given what's at stake with judges and
everything else that we've seen max asks
path forward for progressives in the
next decade let's finish this primary
first before we get into sort of
disaster planning of that kind more EP
says if Biden wins I'm not voting watch
it burn I simply disagree with you Maury
I disagree with you if we see Ruth Bader
Ginsberg replaced with another
conservative justice that will wreak
havoc for a very very long time I don't
want to see that I won't participate in
that
Zachary Monroe says Politico has
updated polls yes they do Bernie has one
Biden still at 17% and Texas is now
razor thin so I if Texas is close to a
tie it's very very bad for Bernie Bernie
needs a margin of victory in Texas the
margin has now increased to 112
delegates and Bernie very very much
needs to win Texas by something if it's
anywhere close to tied California is
just not gonna be enough until unless
Biden ends up being completely not
viable it's not gonna be enough and
Biden is going to come away tonight with
a not insignificant lead flaccid donkey
ass could you go Gary Johnson over
Bloomberg don't know I'd have to think
about it I don't know Gary Johnson's
policies offhand Blake Barker at Blake
barber how do you explain expanding
support for senility that is a question
that is a bigger issue in general about
the age of a lot of these candidates
that that's a there's no question that
that's an important important issue big
picture okay it appears as though the
that Biden is going to end up being
viable again if I had to bet on it I
don't hang my hat on Biden will end up
under 15% I don't see that happening
God Wings 101 says if Biden wins the
primary then it will be four more years
of Trump and we will have earned it he
isn't a return to normalcy he's running
to put the mask back on the political
machine echo factor love from Canada for
Bernie can't believe Republican
messaging around Medicare for all our
system isn't perfect but we don't go
broke if we get sick fear mongering BS
okay very very important comment so it
could be ours until we get results from
California we unfortunately have a sense
of the big picture tonight and so we are
going to end our coverage on that note I
will have the final numbers to the
extent that we will know them tomorrow
thank you to everyone
who
join me I really appreciate it we will
stream more results as they come in
good night from